it's official Ron DeSantis has announced
he is running for president he filed
earlier today and in a Twitter space uh
I we didn't actually get to hear first
because the Twitter space crashed I
think several times and it dropped down
from like 700 000 people down to about
like 98 and that was around like 100 and
some odd thousand I think when he
formally announced that he was running
and uh oof
yeah Elon and Ron are getting roasted
over this and I I I'm not I'm not here
to drag out of those guys I think they
did something that was uh it was
interesting launching a presidential
campaign on Twitter was a bold move but
Twitter was not able to handle it they
just didn't have the technology and um
and and in this uh announcement you got
this one dude uh what's I can't remember
a guy's name David something this uh I
think is a reporter he says maybe maybe
this is the biggest biggest room ever
and I'm like yeah no uh Red Bull had
like four million people watching live
when the guy jumped from outer space and
we had 200 000 live when Stephen Crowder
was here in January so the initial
announcement could have been big but I
really do think they pulled wind out of
their sails and then you know it crashed
I don't blame them for that they
overloaded it it was very popular but uh
it is official we're gonna talk about
this and I think the biggest critique
that I have is uh man
Milo was correct about Rhonda Santos and
Charisma and we'll get into it in great
detail because I do think Ron is is a
fantastic politician I think he's got
great policies I think he's doing
amazing things in Florida but there's
just something we have to talk about
when it comes to a presidential race so
we'll get to know that before we do my
friends head over to timcast.com click
that join us button to become a member
and support our work directly and as a
member you'll get access to our Discord
server and members only uncensored shows
Monday through Thursday at about 10 10
p.m they go live on the front page at
timcast.com and if you're a member for
at least six months or you sign up the
25 per month level you can actually
submit questions and call into the show
so smash that like button subscribe to
this channel share the show with your
friends joining us tonight to talk about
this and so much more is Tyler Boyer hey
what's up how's it going man who are you
what do you do I'm the CEO by day of
Turning Point action by night I am the
National Committee man on the RNC for
Arizona right on so you're doing a lot
of stuff yeah a little bit yeah right on
well good to have you here that was that
was simple we got ready to be here we
got Seamus Coughlin I'm Sheamus England
creator of Freedom Tunes we release
cartoons every week usually twice a week
we're actually not releasing a video
tomorrow we decided to push it off till
Tuesday because I think that'll give us
more time to really improve the quality
of what we're working on I also have a
podcast called shamer which we will be
airing tomorrow on Rumble at 6 PM
Eastern
hello everybody I am Phil Lamonte I'm
the lead singer of All That Remains I am
an anti-communist and I'm a counter
revolutionary and we are here with and I
am surge.com uh rest in peace tuna
Turner I have to say that amen yeah and
uh yeah let's get started all right
here's the official story from the Daily
Mail biggest fail in campaign launches
in history Ron DeSantis is mocked for
shambolic Twitter room presidential
announcement with Elon Musk that crashes
five times and leaves users bamboozled
yeah it was around six o'clock or a few
minutes before six I get that
notification because Elon is about to
start this Twitter space we're really
excited to hear this
I was really excited to hear it and it
started late and then wasn't working and
a lot of people uh man I gotta tell you
I like Elon Musk it does great work I
like Rhonda sanity does great work but I
am not gonna pull punches on this one
the obvious mistakes they were making
they did not properly plan for this I
have no idea how it came off so bad for
one I understand if there's more people
than you expect but this is a
presidential announcement getting
hundreds of thousands of people was
obvious when we had we had Stephen
Crowder on this show we hit about 200
000 viewers okay now if you're gonna
have Ron DeSantis and Elon Musk you got
to prepare for that I presume they did
to the best of their abilities but
Twitter wasn't able to handle it but
here's the thing a lot of people were
saying oh you know the servers were
overloading I was I I understand it
happens no no no no look some of the
problem was like the main host guy was
like he muted himself randomly and I
don't think he noticed he was talking in
the mid side it's just mute and then
Elon unmuted himself while I think I was
talking so you got an echo because they
were sitting next to each other I'm like
dude those are production mistakes not
technical errors and if this was done on
YouTube it probably would have had
substantially more live viewers
I think I think decision was going for a
a big bang gimmick we'll do this on
Twitter spaces with Elon it's huge for
us but they weren't ready for it and it
really pulled a lot of wind out of their
sales now there's a lot of things we can
talk about in terms of around his head
Rhonda Sanders has a candidate but uh
you know what do you guys think
yeah no I agree with you these are
technical problems that should have been
sorted out long ahead of time uh it's
kind of perplexing whenever you see a
massive campaign that's well funded and
has a you know a lot of backing behind
it
fail at something so basic I mean it
happens the best of us everybody makes
mistakes but it's just such a lost
opportunity I heard that uh it was
because someone because they were using
musk's account because he has so many
followers that caused an issue I don't
know how true that is it's just
something I read
um so I don't know but I I mean it was
better right it shouldn't matter I mean
again if they just did it on YouTube
they'd had a million plus viewers and it
would run fine yeah totally I mean or
Rumble this was almost clobuchar
blizzard like level right like that like
let's let's be real Klobuchar blizzard
level it was near near that but yeah
they should have been prepared there's
no question about it now they're getting
roasted it was it is funny though that
uh at first the media was like oh it's
stupid it's gonna fizzle then it got so
much attention that it crashed it's a
lot of people man don't get me wrong it
I think that it it was a good it would
have been a a good thing had it gone
properly
um I think that the fact that it was
that DeSantis has totally been ignoring
the Legacy Media
um I think that's a good thing right
um I also think that it's good because
it kind of puts the Legacy see media on
notice obviously when you've got you
know
organizations like Vanity Fair running
that that headline they did where they
say that they they should have been Dave
brought David Duke or whatever I was
dying you know it's ridiculous of course
um and the the overall tone from The
Establishment media the the Legacy Media
is you know ridiculous so so for
conservatives to go to them and even
even present an opportunity for them to
cover is is almost silly because you
know they're going to say oh well you're
just a racist Nazi huh and so there's no
reason to talk to him when the Twitter
space got to around 460 000 people it
was crashing it was it was crashing well
before that but I got in right when it
started and then rapidly it rises I
tweeted out looks like 460k might be the
limit this uh Twitter user lofty pixels
responded YouTube had 750 000 live
viewers for PlayStation showcase today
lol and posted this video from
PlayStation that had no problem with
this let me show you some of the red
actions we got we've got uh Donald Trump
Jr saying hashtag disaster
yikes man yeah just given ammunition yup
that's a hashtag that's that's better
than desanctimonious yeah yeah way
better seriously way better that's Trump
Jr and then I think I got one more here
we go David wolf tweets Failure to
Launch crashed Rhonda Sanders 2024 and
uh sad faces from Ron and Elon looks
kind of like CGI
yeah yeah it looks a little AI right
well I mean there they're taking you
know they're not just taking a swing at
DeSantis they're taking a swing and musk
because the Twitter thing and the whole
rocket crashing you know making the the
link to SpaceX and stuff you know well
you brought up something interesting I
think it might have screwed up
everything if it was elon's account that
screwed everything up and it switched
over to David sacks that's what I heard
it would change the whole vibe of the
whole thing where it wasn't like Elon
asking DeSantis questions it's just like
it became like David I got in the middle
of it when it when it first launched
Elon was the host then DeSantis then I
think sax joined yeah and they both had
speaking privileges and one of the
technical problems was that while sax
was speaking Elon unmuted his phone and
they're sitting next to each other so
you start hearing a feedback loop and
then Boomer stuff that's but for Elon to
do that like why did you unmute your
account what are you doing here well
then it became David sacks asking all
the questions and nobody was supposed to
be and it wasn't supposed to be no it
was supposed to be oh it was supposed to
be I mean they they they might say oh it
was supposed to be Elon I don't I don't
see that why bring in sex at all he was
brought in before DeSantis yeah so isn't
he was he like a British journalist or
something no I mean he was he was like
the CEO of PayPal I think oh okay okay
so they're they're buds but they but I
mean the whole thing was sold is like
Elon asking the questions right like
even like we were going to the War Room
hosting a space yeah it's supposed to be
like the Elon interview type thing and
it didn't really happen
yeah it it didn't really it's just like
softball City and then after the crash
it just uh was was it was just not good
I mean it's just it's like I mean a lot
of people left
that took a lot of wind out of the sales
I mentioned it yesterday dude yesterday
we wanted to lead the show off with the
uh the target story because now it's
getting crazier Target is uh apparently
the CEO she had a statement saying yeah
we're gonna get rid of a bunch of stuff
but we're gonna Double Down basically
saying we're gonna try and hide this in
the general public but instead I'm like
okay they basically released this launch
video so we have to cover it but then
what is there to cover today if not just
the same thing we already know okay
dude's running for president then of
course we got lucky in that they failed
so like they I I should a little mean
it's a little mean they did do the space
they did get the message out they did
get the announcement but I I do feel
like uh we got news out of the fact that
they kind of screwed up the launch and
they lost the majority of the audience
that was ready for this announcement but
it was like a snooze Fest yeah it was it
was just news I mean like you got in
there and you're like wow there's
nothing interesting here you got to come
with some well I mean no bangers I I
left relatively quickly the new the only
news that was there was was it being
done on a space everyone knew that the
Santa
DeSantis didn't have anything there was
no Pizzazz to his actual speech or
anything so like really come with
something so it's like it really was the
interesting thing was the fact that it
was on Twitter for the first time and
then it felt went back they ruined it
could you imagine if Elon abruptly
launched a space and then said Rhonda
said isn't making a big announcement
that would have crashed all of Twitter
way faster than this would have so maybe
maybe they're trying to avoid that but
even in that regard DeSantis really
screwed this one up his Camp his
campaign because they could have gone on
Rumble and they could have been with Dan
bongino and that would have would have
held up just fine but he was like ooh
Elon Musk he's big we're gonna go for
this if he abruptly appeared on a live
stream with Dan bongino and Dan was like
I'm being joined by Iran I don't know if
Dan would want to do that because he's
more of a trump guy anyway but if Ron
did a show any any live stream and they
tweeted out Rhonda sentences here and
he's about to make an announcement you'd
get two million live viewers instead
they were like let's announce it
announce exactly what we're gonna
announce and then have a crash and it's
just like they end up with 190 000 or
some of my people listening when Rhonda
Sanders makes his presidential
announcement and I was just like it's
good but for a presidential announcement
come on dude we had Stephen Crowder in
here on January we cracked that number
and he didn't even announce he was
running for president right yeah no he
was complaining he was just complaining
internet drama his internet drama
PlayStation like I mentioned did a
Showcase of video games at 757 000
people
that's brutal man yeah he should have
maybe saved this Elon moment for
something that was like really
newsworthy
you know like a big deal like something
like like the Stephen Crowder moment
right like where everybody's paying
attention and they're hanging on every
word they could have saved this for
something big at the right moment to
drop during the campaign I feel like hmm
yeah I don't know if this was the moment
I don't know this is like everybody knew
was coming it's like they brought
nothing into the table it's a bad start
yeah I mean do you think it was just an
effort to associate himself with Elon
because Elon is not necessarily on the
right or left but the radical left
really hates him and the establishment
is trying to fight him or vice versa I
don't know man I I don't I I think
what's interesting out of this is Trump
versus Elon I think that's a more
interesting Dynamic I think this is
going to be like I think Trump's gonna
attack Elon more than he's gonna attack
anybody else over the course of the next
Elon interest oh they I mean they he
attacks Elon all the time I don't see
how I mean that's good in any way
I don't I don't think so either I just
think it's interesting it's gonna be
interesting to see him attack Elon
coming out of this thing as like I mean
he's like you know who he reminds me of
a little bit I don't know if you guys
know Sheriff show Arpaio yeah Sheriff
Joe and Phoenix where I'm from remembers
every single person that wronged him
ever and puts them on a list and attacks
that no no no no no Daylights out Trump
doesn't do that Trump is Trump attacks
you only until you're nice to him yeah
as soon as you're nice to him then he's
but he's with you Trump is is
yeah I mean we'll see if Elon you can be
pro-trump and still be honest the guy is
like the guy has no principle he's his
principle is winning he's saying tiny
Ron DeSantis yeah after the primary he's
gonna say Titan Rhonda exactly Titan
Rhonda said he's a big man he's a big
this is one of the things Trump really
uh understands about politics very well
you know so many people in media will
Lampoon him for that kind of behavior
the fact that he'll just do a complete
180 on a person and I agree there's
something there that's laughable but the
media does that constantly they're
equally Shameless did you see uh Bill
Crystal I think called Trump and Alpha
today or yesterday it's it's so typical
and what they'll also do is you know
they will forward a narrative that
narrative will be completely disproven
and it'll just jump to something else or
sometimes they'll jump to a different
narrative which is completely
contradictory to what they were stating
their goals are when representing the
other narrative so the media will take
advantage of the American people having
this short attention span and not
considering how current statements line
up against past statements and then
they'll laugh at Trump for doing the
exact same thing let's uh let's let's do
it we're gonna play the announcement it
for you it's a it's a I guess it's seven
minutes long and uh before I start I
just want to mention we have a super
chat from uh where where are we at who
who said it
um beagle cakes says who has I don't
know who has more Charisma Mark
Zuckerberg or Rhonda Santos so I mean
it's a little biased start but let's
just play the play the video for you
Zuckerberg because you can Roll Jiu
Jitsu yeah um I understand that you may
have an announcement to make we've got I
think a record audience assembled here
uh you know probably the biggest uh room
that's probably ever been assembled
online uh what what would you like that
was such a sad statement yeah there's
102 people listening 102 000 and is it
probably the biggest online what do you
say ever
bumbled here uh you know the probably
the biggest uh room that's probably ever
been assembled online what would you
like to tell them
well I am running for president of the
United States to lead our Great American
comeback look we know our country's
going in the wrong direction we see it
with our eyes and we feel it in our
bones our Southern borders collapse
drugs are pouring into the country our
cities are being hollowed out by spiking
crime the federal government's making it
harder for the average family to make
ends meet and to attain and maintain a
middle-class lifestyle and our president
well he lacks Vigor flounders in the
face of our nation's challenges and he
takes his cues from the woke mob I don't
think it has to be this way American
decline is not inevitable it is a choice
and we should choose a new Direction a
path that will lead to American
revitalization we must restore sanity to
our nation this means embracing fiscal
and economic sanity stop pricing
hard-working Americans out of a good
standard of living through inflationary
borrow print and spending policies and
please Embrace American Energy
Independence this also means replacing
the woke mind virus with reality facts
and enduring principles Merit must Trump
identity politics we must return
normalcy to our communities America is a
sovereign country our borders must be
respected we cannot have foreigners
pouring into our country illegally by
the millions we cannot allow drug
cartels to poison our population with
fentanyl public deserve safe communities
and Law and Order must be maintained in
American cities we can't have inmates
running the Asylum and we must reject
attacks on the men and women of law
enforcement we also must re-establish
Integrity in our institutions this
includes the military I'm proud to be a
Navy veteran and Iraq veteran and I
Revere our services but when revered
institutions like those in our military
are more concerned with matters not
Central to the mission whether it's
global warming or gender ideology and
pronoun pounds morale declines and
recruiting suffers and you need to
eliminate these distractions and we need
to get focused on the core Mission we
also cannot have true constitutional
government if the most significant
issues are decided by the whims of
unelected bureaucrats rather than the
people's elected representatives
re-establishing Integrity in our
institutions means we must reinvigorate
our constitutional system by returning
the government to its rightful owners We
the People no social that was just come
up without representation truth needs to
be our foundation oh my gosh it's only
been two minutes and 50 seconds virtue
and in Florida
we chose facts over fear indication over
indoctrination Law and Order over
rioting and disorder we the words are
great right the words are great the
delivery but it's like an AI saying it
exactly it's like it's not even like an
ad it's like a text message
recently ranked number one in education
we have a 50-year low crime rate and one
of the lowest tax in debt per capita in
America but we also understand governing
is not entertainment it's not about
building a brand or virtue signaling is
about deliverance
and our results in Florida have been
Second To None we can and we must
deliver big results for America I pledge
to be an energetic executive
look me up
first
and we'll build an economy where working
Americans can achieve a good standard of
living Biden's opened the southern
border and allowed massive amounts of
drugs to pour into the country we'll
shut down the Border construct the
border wall and hold the drug cartel
we're building accountable bidens
Embrace medical authoritarianism such as
unconstitutional covid vax mandates we
will ensure that those violations of
Liberty can never happen again Biden's
allowed woke ideology to drive his
agenda we will never surrender to the
woke mob and we will leave woke ideology
into Dustbin of History come on Biden's
also politicized the military to plummet
we will eliminate ideological agendas
from our military Focus the military on
the core Mission and we will reverse the
poor recruiting Trends finally Biden's
weaponized the power of the
administrative State this is a cruel and
unusual publishing agenda we will
reconstitutionalize the executive branch
and will bring the administrative state
to heal now you can't do any of that if
you don't win there is no substitute for
victory we must then the culture of
losing that has infected the Republican
party in recent years the tired dogmas
of the past are inadequate for a vibrant
future we must look forward
backwards we need the courage to lead
and we must have the strength to win and
to voters who are participating in this
primary process my pledge to you is this
if you nominate me you can set your
clock to January 20th 2025 at High Noon
because on the west side of the U.S
Capitol I will be taking the oath of
office as the 47th president of the
United States no excuses I will get the
job done now these past few years have
given me a new appreciation for the
fragility of our freedoms I never
thought I would see things in America
that we saw during the covid-19 pandemic
but our founding fathers were keenly
aware of the fragility of Freedom when
they framed our constitution they came
to armed with having studied the history
of every Republic in the history of
mankind and they noticed that all of
those experiments only had one thing in
common and it was this every single one
of them had failed and so they knew it
fell to our country the United States of
America to determine whether people
could really govern themselves could we
have a society based on the idea that
our rights are god-given not government
granted and that Society functions based
on the rule of law not the rule of
individual men and when Dr Benjamin
Franklin walked out of that convention
he was asked did you deliver a republic
or a monarchy he said a republic if you
can keep it they knew Freedom didn't run
on emphasis on you the only thing has a
responsibility to safeguard freedom and
it's our responsibility to do so at this
important juncture in our nation's
history we have a lot of work to do to
ensure the country gets back on track I
ask everybody listening to please join
me on this Mission please invest in our
campaign by going to Ron desantis.com
and making a donation thank you God
bless and I look forward to the
discussion
look I really I want to turn it off but
it's like a presidential announcement so
I thought like for the sake of hearing
it people need to be able to hear it but
dude yeah I I couldn't believe it when
he got to the part about a republic if
you can keep it I'm like listen man I
like Rhonda Sanders as a politician he
has great policies he's doing a great
job
but holy crap did they not give this guy
one minute of media training did they
not have any kind of of campaign coach
be like go watch Captain America one
time
and just watch watch any Hollywood movie
where the protagonist gives a speech
about saving the world just just that in
fact watch SNL as they mock that look
man
the Santa's people are probably gonna
get mad because they like him but I'm
not pulling punches I like Elon I like
to say at this but that had negative
Charisma negative I agree I look I I
like DeSantis a lot I think everything
he was saying there was spot on every
single word but I'll be honest I was I
was literally bored to tears I mean it's
remarkable to me that someone who said
so many things that were so true that
would have gotten a standing ovation
from any group of conservatives who are
outside of the establishment where they
just delivered with a little bit more
energy could be so boring when addressed
in such a plain monotone way I think
that you're right he needs media
training again I'm not trying to be
harsh on the guy there's all there's a
lot about DeSantis which is really
really great he has to fix this I has to
fix guys I really don't want to play
this video for you
because it's just I don't think Rhonda
said his has the has the personality for
for being president
but for the sake of just letting you
guys watch it for yourselves this is
Rhonda Santos's tweeted Out official
announcement video
[Applause]
fests are cities
federal government makes it harder for
families to make ends meet and the
president flounders but decline is a
choice success is attainable and freedom
is worth fighting for writing the ship
requires restoring sanity to our society
normalcy to our communities and
integrity to our institutions
truth must be our foundation and Common
Sense can no longer be an uncommon
virtue in Florida we prove that it can
be done the music we chose facts over
fear education over indoctrination Law
and Order over rioting and disorder we
held the line when Freedom hung in the
bounds we showed that we can and must
Revitalize America we need the courage
to lead and the strength to win I'm Ron
DeSantis and I'm running for president
to lead our Great American comeback
I'm gonna I'm gonna say something
shockingly offensive to all the Genesis
fans oh boy
Joe Biden's got better presence and
presentation than Rhonda Santos does now
now hold on there a minute before you
freak out Joe Biden does have a mental
Affliction yeah which gives Joe Biden to
make it entertaining yeah when Biden
says
pressure okay like we get it that's
incomprehensible mumbled garbage but at
the very least let me let me let me play
a little bit for you sanity to our
society normalcy to our communities and
integrity to our institutions
truth must be our foundation now imagine
how Joe Biden would deliver that yeah we
got to bring some some Integrity man
some truth emotions come on man
I think I mentioned this before the show
but I think DeSantis needs to be able to
announce that he's running for president
with at least the same amount of energy
that Joe Biden announced he had hairy
legs with seriously I mean we we need
some actual Spirit Behind these
statements again I got hairy legs like
he meant it I was like I believe you I
believe
super weird you're very creepy but I do
believe your legs are hairy okay there's
some level of enthusiasm you need and
part of the reason that this is so
difficult for people is because DeSantis
and Trump even though they're Rivals
they've been associated with each other
in many ways right The Establishment has
smeared DeSantis in somewhat similar
ways to the ways they smeared Trump uh
before they started running against each
other their bases were similar but the
thing you got to remember is Trump was
an outsider DeSantis is a politician
even though he's not in line with the
establishment on many of the things that
they want him to be in line with them on
uh he's still a politician and he does
kind he I mean he has that boring
political way of speaking and I I would
go as far as to say it's actually worse
for him than it is a lot of other
politicians so part of it is we have
this expectation sent by Trump that we
should have a leader who's really going
to be charismatic and energetic and also
the fact that DeSantis is like even more
boring than most other politicians are
when he speaks even though I like what
the guy does even though he's he's very
much impressed me I mean one of one of
the things he said earlier on quite a
long time ago is that he didn't want to
be in a political Foxhole with anyone
who isn't pro-life I think that's
fantastic I mean I think that is
fantastic there's a lot he does that's
phenomenal but man you gotta you gotta
tune the energy up man we'll turn the
energy up so I have his quote
it's he said but we know our country's
going in the wrong direction we see it
with our own eyes and we feel it in our
bones I am running for president of the
United States to lead our Great American
comeback
if you were to imagine Joe Biden saying
that he'd say something like but we know
our country's going in the wrong
direction we see their own eyes come on
man we're feeling our bones I read that
he'd probably say we fill in our Biggums
yeah I don't know what that word is but
but there's like I'm not trying to say
that Joe Biden conveys ideas properly no
but the emotions in those ideas he has a
lot of big feelings yeah good old job I
mean running big events I mean we run
some of the biggest events at turning
point and Shout out we have we just
announced that Trump's gonna be speaking
in our big action conference uh on July
15th and 16th of West Palm Beach but uh
right before this but doing this I think
what was the weird part about this whole
announcement is you have to warm up the
speaker they should have treated this
whole thing like it was he was going on
stage I mean they had a video of him on
a big stage it's him in front of a flag
without cheering all of the back none of
it felt like there was a big crowd there
so they're put they're showing this
video of him like Solo in front of a
flag and they're on Twitter spaces and
he came in cold after after technical
difficulty why did they have a whole
program where it was like warm-up
speakers get the crowd hyped like add to
the like the way like they should have
built the thing up to be hundreds of
thousands of followers anything that
that exact video would have been fine if
they didn't use pensive staccato violins
yes data had better music that actually
had some impact I'm telling you I am
telling you I think the visual of him
just like alone though I guarantee that
music was pensive that's that made
people feel anxiety it didn't feel epic
seriously that kind of that kind of
biking absolutely no no look look I
think the music is fine but not with
this presentation I think the
presentation could work if it had better
music you get this really intense boom
and he's going and we've got to have
truth in our nation it's like they do
not go together let me point out this
one piece here you're not able to see
him on this Twitter space right which I
think is so stupid I mean this is is it
yeah what is this this isn't like the
early 20th century you can't see the guy
I know this is basically like radio he's
basically an FDR you know he could he he
couldn't walk maybe he couldn't walk
maybe he maybe he didn't have
functioning legs we wouldn't know with
him he's using this medium that nobody
can see him with a video they should
have built this whole thing where it was
like his whole production they've had
months and months and months and months
that where it's like he's in a room with
a lot of people why can't you why can't
you do this whole thing in a room with a
lot of people yeah yeah no I mean it's a
good point I think you were absolutely
spot on when he said there should have
been an audience there energy stage
there should have been people but
warm-up act yeah I'm actually I'm
actually but this this is sort of what
I'm saying right it's it's remarkable to
me when something with so much money and
power behind it is done so poorly I mean
these are really basic things you don't
have to be an expert political analyst
to know that those things would have
helped him and not just that they would
have helped him but that they're kind of
bare necessities
I just I would have thought they would
have at least had some kind of General
Media training and and what gets me is
that was their finished product that was
them saying we we got it did we get it
we got it we're good we're good we're on
there yeah like when we watch these
Biden videos and they're jump cutting
like crazy because you know the dude is
completely incapable of speaking at this
point
you watch that and I'm just thinking to
myself it's the best thing they wrapped
they went to the ad and said guys this
is it they could have called him back in
and said Hey Ron we really need to have
a coach here who's going to tell you how
to say these lines so like for instance
when I'm doing uh Sheamus will ask me to
read some lines for Freedom Tunes he's
got to be here to tell me how to do the
lines because it might say something
like oh boy I'm gonna go buy an ice
cream cone and then I say oh boy I'm
gonna buy an ice cream cone and then
James will be like no say oh boy I'm
gonna go buy an ice cream coat like you
gotta say it's yeah short here like you
need direction when you didn't have it
when we're like when I'm when I'm
recording like we're doing a record or
whatever there's three things that the
producer is going to tell me he's gonna
tell me either my timing's bad he's
gonna tell me my notes are bad or he's
going to tell me I don't believe it you
gotta believe it you have to be
performing if you're up there and you're
talking to a crowd you need the crowd to
believe what you're saying they need to
believe that you believe it that's the
first thing and this you have to believe
it you have to tell them that that that
that you believe it and this is why
Trump basically always crushes right
because he always yes always sells that
he believes it this is why he can get
away with going on television and saying
something completely different than he
said a few days ago about a particular
person
he believes it exactly exactly he's
really in it people likely he shows up
and just starts talking yeah yeah
there's a weird element to that that
people like they've liked since day one
and that's what lit a fire under people
to be like oh you know what I don't like
Ted Cruz anymore I like Donald Trump
that's what happens in 16. so the the
Trump Camp released a video
exactly at the moment I guess the
Twitter space crashed yeah and so I want
you I want to play this guys for you uh
play this for you guys this uh contrasts
the Trump campaign with the Santa's
campaign at the same time that he was
launching
the Washington established politicians
like to talk about how they can be just
like Donald Trump the truth
there's only one Donald Trump
only one who gave us the largest tax
cuts in history who gave vets the health
care they deserve and up to China and
protected your job only one who kept us
out of endless Wars while destroying our
terrorist enemies only one who
fundamentally changed the Supreme Court
was called the most pro-life president
in history and relentlessly protected
our second amendments
for Trump Impostors make America great
again when there's only one starting day
one who can make America great
again I'm Donald J Trump and I approve
this message
look how like very epic this video's not
this is not an announcement when Trump
made his announcement earlier it was a
lot lower energy but still better than
Sanders now I'd like to play for you a
DeSantis War Room clip released uh just
about 45 minutes ago and uh here here it
here it is one second if you remember
that the music I'm sorry the music that
Trump had we need an honest Reckoning
about what happened during covid I mean
the only honest Reckoning is that all of
those agencies all of the elites the
public health establishment they failed
they instituted bad policies okay I
can't play anymore why is Elon Musk in
this yeah what is this video it's the
weirdest this is the weirdest war room
post I've ever seen of anyone's war room
in the history of War rooms this is
crazy
I
I'm just I'm I'm when that space
happened and I got my phone open and I'm
sitting in my living room and I'm like
all right let's hear it I just went no
they're disconnected are you kidding me
Barack Obama so a lot of people uh I see
one Super Chat you know people are
saying like well what about the policies
we know the policies are good we've
repeatedly said exact policies that's
why we want but did Barack Obama get
elected on policy yeah did Donald Trump
get elected on policy sort of Donald
Trump gets elected by being authentic by
going on stage and when the me when
Megan Kelly tries calling about saying
you called women fat pigs did he go well
no I I you were mistaken he went only
Rosie O'Donnell and everyone started
busting out laughing he didn't he didn't
deflect he didn't say well that's not
true that's out of context he didn't try
lying he just owned it he owned that
they were in a smear it was like yeah
Rosie O'Donnell she's like wow it is
impressive to see the media take a swing
at the king and Miss yeah with this oh
man well that's the thing well no I just
want to say everyone's going oh but his
policies are good his policies are good
we know that's why this critique is in
important because we're saying we want
the policies that he's going to promote
in this country to flourish in order for
them to be able to do so he has to be
elected right and whether he's elected
in the primaries or whether he runs for
president later on whether it's it's the
2024 cycle or 2028 this guy has to do
something about his presence Barack
Obama blew up kids and got reelected yes
so when you come and you're like but the
policies I'm like no I know the policies
are great we can praise them all day and
night I can say it over at best Governor
best policies fighting ESG fighting the
wokeness man I love that stuff and then
he goes up on stage to speak in front of
a bunch of Americans who don't pay
attention to politics who don't know
anything about policy and he goes I
think truth it matters in this country
and they're like who is this born
exactly it's boring Barack Obama was a
celebrity he got elected because he was
Charming look at Trudeau they said
Trudeau got elected because women found
him attractive or I'm sorry I should say
women voted for him many said they voted
for him because he was attractive he was
dreamy or something he did that that
yoga handstand the desk and he's a
surfer and they're like oh wow people
don't look to leaders based on doing
deep analytical research on their policy
positions they vote for them if they
have Charisma exactly and and by the way
I think it's a good thing all the
elections today are decided by low
propensity
swing voters and swing districts and
swing States so when you when you break
you want to break this down Republicans
for Republicans Democrats are going to
vote for Democrats and you have this
fragment that exists of people who
really don't want to vote and the
Democrats are chasing down those voters
and those ballots better than we are so
it's like who's going to Hype up their
people more and give people more energy
to go actually chase down those ballots
and build that well exactly and so you
might be sitting there saying like why
vote based on policy yes no me too
that's what you should vote based on
guess what that's not why most people
vote so we got to figure out what makes
most people vote really make somebody
win and then if you want DeSantis to win
if we want DeSantis to win we gotta find
a way for him to cultivate those things
if those policies really matter all that
much to you it's Charisma if you have
Charisma you can you'll be able to
convince voters you can convince voters
without a message that's what hope and
change was that's what make America
great is it's a it's an empty shell that
people can fill with whatever they
believe is important you can take this
message and then you get to go ahead and
put your values into it and that's so
really all you need is Riz all you need
is charisma all you need to do is be
able to convince people someone said uh
on Twitter we lost Tina Turner and Ron
DeSantis on the same night oh wow oh
they come in threes I'm just I'm just
surprised that when you look at Barack
Obama how I ended up winning how
Democrats often win right they got to be
Charming they got to be charismatic Bill
Clinton you've got to come out there and
you've got to speak with passion Joe
Biden is good faking the passion and
using his his dead son as a political
tool to earn to earn sympathy I mean
this guy is is evil as they come just
had it seems like a good guy
but nobody went to him and said we're
going to get you some some training
nobody nobody said hey that was a little
dry can we try it again he had nobody's
in there being like when you say freedom
say freedom don't say freedom no Freedom
yeah freedom
well what concerns me more is that
nobody was on his campaign and I know
some of the people that run his campaign
great people but nobody was on this
campaign that went hey maybe we should
really turn this into an entire like a
really well planned event like as if it
were live like we shouldn't build this
thing out to make it seem like it's much
bigger than just the Twitter space
because we can make it seem like
everyone's listening on Twitter but that
it's a bigger thing that they're not
there a part of and now they're part of
something that's bigger that would have
been a bigger grander plan I mean it
just it just goes to show that the
energy is not there with Ron DeSantis
but the energy is not there with his
campaign and the people are surrounding
him that are figuring out what actually
works with with the Maga base that they
have to try to court which they're not
doing at all that's how you have to win
you have to pull away some votes from
Trump so you've got DeSantis basically
saying what Trump is saying
in no way saying the only thing he's
offered as to why he's better than Trump
is that he doesn't think Trump can win
it's like okay if that's your attitude
then people are going to be like okay
I'll take either one you're you're not
making the argument for vote for me
because I'll win you're making the
argument of either way it doesn't matter
um yep it's really it's it's ridiculous
if he's like well I think I'll win it's
like okay your policies are the same all
right see you in November well and
that's also yeah that this is the
mistake the Republicans have made in the
past we saw this with the lack of a red
wave during the midterms the entire
Republican narrative was Red Wave Red
Wave Red Wave there's going to be a red
wave and so there wasn't any actual
unified messaging about anything else
and they just assumed that they were
gonna step in there and claim all these
victories I think DeSantis is probably
making the same assumption based on his
behavior he's thinking I'll just step
into the ring against Trump and I'll win
because I'm more electable well dude you
got to work up to that you can't just
make that assumption Milo was right when
he came on the show and he said that Ron
DeSantis had the uh Charisma of
something off-putting like when you
reach for something and accidentally
touch something moist like a wet sponge
I don't know I would go that far I just
he really bored me he was saying things
that I completely agree with I should
have been cheering for that speech and I
was yawning but honestly that's what
he's been told to do though right I mean
they're like we need to win female
voters back we went we need to win mom's
back well guess what guys in a primary
if it comes down to men vote for Trump
and women vote for DeSantis Trump's
gonna kill the scientists because more
men are gonna show up for the primary or
not only that but a lot of a lot of
the women who are voting are not going
to just be for DeSantis because
descendants is calm if they're primary
voters it could be a coin toss yes but
then guys are more likely going to be
attracted to the gruff aggressive
attitude alpha male but it could be if
if all all the head is rolling was
rolling for us maybe people would prefer
my attitude more and I said it before
right if we had someone as good as Trump
but with a better demeanor it'd be great
but Ronda Sanders doesn't have the
leadership Charisma to win now if he
wins the primary he's got my vote no
question yeah of course he's fantastic
of course his his policies are only
mediocre because in my opinion if you
look at Trump's announcement the ones
that we went over the other night I have
significantly more uh Stronger
preference for the stuff that Trump was
talking about than DeSantis DeSantis
gave the standard Republican
stuff I mean it was as as boilerplate
boring everyday Republican as it can get
and that's I think that's because he's
trying to say look I'm not as Extreme as
Donald Trump even though he's going to
say he's gonna try to attack Trump from
the right apparently is that that's the
that's the the goal I guess but it's
even still if you look at Trump's the
the list that Trump gave the other day
that we were going over compared to
DeSantis I think that Trump is actually
offering better has a better grasp on
the things that I'm interested in like
really tearing up the bureaucracy well I
was out whether or not he actually will
do it I don't know but I was at
Mar-A-Lago for Trump's announcement and
I remember everybody going wow he came
in really soft he was so soft he was
like so I don't know if you remember
he's or if you guys talk uh just talked
to a really little voice and when I do
it that's because Trump needs to be more
soft Ron DeSantis needs to be more alpha
male to sell himself and he didn't
really produce that tonight yeah so you
made an interesting point Phil about the
fact that DeSantis is going to try to
attack Trump from the right and this is
what always happens during primary
Seasons right when Republicans primary
they try to be as far to the right as
possible so that they can appeal to the
hard-line conservative base and then
when people on the left are running in
the primaries they're as far left as
possible and then when whoever is
selected is in the national election I I
don't remember saying all those things
or those things aren't relevant whatever
it is but with DeSantis part of what's
really a massive weakness for him is the
thing that he was best on the thing that
the American people were most impressed
with him about was his response to covid
now unfortunately it is the case that
while at the time the things DeSantis
was saying were completely unorthodox
The Establishment entirely rejected them
most Republicans would not want to
associate with you if you were saying
those things because the political
science has changed to quote DeSantis
these are perspectives that you're
allowed to have so that takes a lot of
desantises edge away unfortunately even
though he was on the right side of this
virtually the entire time because the
status quo is changed he doesn't seem
like an outsider anymore yeah
yeah well and that and that's what
happened to Cruz right was Cruz was The
Outsider in 2016. Cruz was the outside
guy everyone was like oh I want to vote
for Ted Cruz it's a little bit naughty
you know with all this because the
establishment was going to attack every
single person that supported Cruz Cruz
had this massive following he has I
think he had the most like
okay one Iowa it ended up just being
barely but he he had all the most small
dollar donations and then all of a
sudden it just imploded because all
these establishment guys dropped out
dropped out drop down started supporting
Crews well guess what if establishment
guys are dropping out and all these
consultants and all these different
states are trying to get contracts
they're not going to to Donald Trump for
the most part they're going to be going
to Ron desantis's group and he's going
to have a plan to have to deflect these
people and there's no plan the uh last
year I was saying that I was I was
leaning towards DeSantis I was ready you
know I've never been a big Trump guy
Trump wouldn't stop talking about me me
and talking about what was taken from
him he needs to get back on that message
of this is what they took from you he
needs to get back on the message of you
know with your help my election brought
you a better economy safer borders
better jobs et cetera an end to Middle
Middle East conflict and then they took
that all the way from you when when Joe
Biden became the president that's his
angle after this launch from monosantis
I I have just lost like because I'm like
I'm like leaning towards Trump Trump's
the guy who's gonna go in and clean
things up but you know detention maybe
at this point I'm like 85 for Trump
because um
it just
the the the the inauthenticity of it
yeah the the Twitter space was scripted
his speeches they're scripted Donald
Trump is a guy who just gets up there
and starts talking and then they go oh
no oh no he's going off the prompter
again he's he's he's he's he's ad living
and he's funny Trump trump is funny he's
he's personable
and uh he's got some he's lucky he
certainly crass and crude and can be
very insulting to people who are mean to
him but what I'm what I'm trying to say
is when he gets up there and talks he
talks in the heart and he just goes for
it DeSantis gets up there and he reads
from his piece of paper in a very stiff
and robotic way and then says thank you
and then walks away and I'm like I don't
even know if you mean it like you were
saying about singing gotta believe it
well I mean every single politician in
2016 I was chairman of Maricopa County
of the Republican Party Maricopa County
we hosted Trump for the what became the
first Trump rally
and I got a chance to meet every single
candidate that ran back in 2016. and
remember we had like 16 of them or
something I can't remember what it was
15 16.
and every single person that you meet
typically in politics is totally
inauthentic they suck you know I mean
even like Ted Cruz like he wouldn't even
talk to people sit in the back of his of
his car that we with a driver playing
Plants versus Zombies the entire time
and it's like Donald Trump when you meet
him he like shakes your hand he's like
I like your tie I like how you're doing
tell me about your life let me see your
kid let me hold your kid let me you know
is this your grandma oh she's so sweet
she has softer hands than you like stuff
like that and like you like the guy
immediately and there's nobody within
politics thus far that I've ever met
that's that authentic that actually
cares about you anybody who went to a
trump rally saw it when the rally ends
he walks up to the barricade and starts
just hanging out with people and I was
like how does this guy have the energy
for this yeah it's well and that's the
thing about Donald Trump right he really
is a once in a lifetime kind of
political leader there is nobody who I'm
aware of in American political history
who's even remotely like him he's very
unique For Better or For Worse some
people don't like that I like that a lot
and there's not gonna be another guy
like him who comes along no you're right
there people can learn from this it's
like guys like learn from it and that's
what I would also say is if you're
heavily invested into Santa's and your
position is DeSantis is way better than
Trump and you believe that okay then you
should want DeSantis to learn some of
that Charisma so that he has a Fighting
Chance
yeah but but don't sit around and act
like there's not a problem when there is
one there is a Charisma problem with
DeSantis I like him you can't pretend
that's not true it is bad it will do no
one any favors to pretend that's not the
case but it's like the Democrats who are
trying to pretend that Joe Biden didn't
have dementia when he was running in the
primaries like you can't not acknowledge
this because this is going to get him
torn to shreds on the national stage so
I think Trump I've said this to people
before I think Trump is like Reagan on
steroids what people liked about Reagan
was that he would get up he'd make jokes
and people were like oh it kind of
reminds me of like my friend or my
grandpa or my uncle like that makes
jokes all the time at Thanksgiving and
like I like that about him and like
Trump is like like Reagan on steroids
when it comes to that but it's why don't
people I I don't understand like how
somebody's running for president and
it's like you don't learn from at least
pieces of that element studying from any
other president in history yeah just
like like the successful ones that are
like that do well Florida's never had a
president have they I was reading
something and said Florida hasn't sent
has never sent a uh you know president I
changed my mind then they're overdue no
uh they are new what are the generals or
are they the Globetrotters man it just
it just bums me out to see such a lost
opportunity yeah that's it's it's you
know first impressions can be everything
and probably in a political in a
political campaign
your announcement speech needs to hit
heavy heavy and this was a was it I mean
first of all like you were saying it's
just there's no video what is it like
radio it's like the event of radio
it's like SDR yeah I mean they really
did not think this through yeah there's
plenty of time there is plenty of time
he could turn these things around that's
also why constructive criticism is valid
and important like I said if you really
like DeSantis you should really be
willing to hear these criticisms and the
people at his campaign should too
because I think this is what the guy I
don't think they are I don't think
they're when I tweeted inoculus like
about jazz Jennings because they're
living in Florida and I said where's
DeSantis his press people start
attacking me on Twitter call me a
grifter they're so out of the they're
they've they I I can't believe how bad
how bad this is no I'm sorry I can
believe it it's just somebody's telling
them like here great policies here's
what people want is that great and then
he goes on stage and just goes
and then his press people are like no
one better insult Ron DeSantis okay well
if your immediate reaction to any light
criticism is to start insulting those
you may as well just be a Democrat you
may as well join the left because your
candidates never going to improve and
you may just be a cult you made an
interesting point about Charisma you
said it makes you feel like that person
is your friend I was thinking the exact
same thing a little bit earlier people
don't realize this you know having that
charismatic power is something that a
person might see as a thing that a
politician needs and therefore a
politician's trade and something that
actually sets you apart from Ordinary
People but it's the exact opposite when
someone isn't charismatic they come off
like any other politician and people
aren't as patient and they're not as
interested in hearing what they say
because it comes off like you said as
fake just comes off as you know this
guy's reading off of a script I'm not
doubting desantis's sincerity I think he
believes everything he read there I'll
say it again I like DeSantis but he
really has to work some energy up he
really needs to get some coaching on how
to be more charismatic nobody in this
room needs a script to explain their
position on the border on crime on war
and on woke ideology yeah no script and
in fact if you were to go up to anybody
in this room and the public and say give
me your thoughts on Modern power
politics and tell me how you feel it
might start soft and then it'll slowly
escalate as we get more impassioned yeah
and and and pulls up that anger of the
things we're frustrated with the things
we want the average Trump voter could do
a better job the average in my opinion
you take a random Trump voter put them
on say to the microphone and say rally
the people and tell them why you're mad
and it's going to be some middle-aged
you know Factory workers and say I lost
my job when they opened up those borders
and they bring in non-citizens to reap
the benefits of my labor and then put me
out of work and the crowd goes well
that's screaming Ron does our borders
are open right and we shouldn't allow oh
man well I I don't think it's a lack of
sincerity I think that there are just
some people who are more monotone their
temperament is such that when they say
things it's less exciting and
interesting again I think that's
something you can work on I think that's
something that could genuinely improve
and by the way room for improvement is
not just a euphemism for you're bad at
this it means you actually could become
better I think DeSantis could become
better at this you brought up a really
interesting point which kind of
overtures with what we were talking
about which is this should have been
programmatic there should have been
someone warming the stage up they should
have built this thing to like a million
concurrent you know listeners or
whatever they should have set a goal
like a bar like Hey we're not going to
send it shouldn't have announced it they
should have announced it it's just got
this thing like organically everybody
get on Twitter right now look
it's really interesting Donald Trump has
done since day one our very first rally
which turned into was the first Trump
rally he his team and I think this is
Corey Lewandowski deserves a credit for
this they had invited Angel moms which
were the moms for everyone that's a
listener everyone here knows it's the
moms who had a child die at the hands of
an illegal immigrant and that happened
in Arizona this was the first rally was
on illegal immigration but he had
invited those people so before he got up
they had like they had done exactly what
you said yep they appealed to the
audience and they're like oh wow I've
never seen a politician do this before
so by the time they got up like
everybody was like in the room like he
did like they could have done that like
again Lessons Learned From they could
have said nothing posted no videos they
should have done it on uh maybe Joe
Rogan if Rogan would have him but like a
Big Show and it should have been on a
platform that can handle it and then
what happens is one I'll report the
announcement they tweet out Rhonda
Sanders could tweet I am joining
whatever show
to discuss you know to discuss a big
change in my life tune in you'll get a
mix of people saying is this gonna be an
announcement is it what's going on
that's got to be the announcement two
million three million people would be
watching and then you would say you
guessed right I am announcing I'm
running here's why that could have at
least made up for some of the Charisma
Gap yeah instead they did this wonky
poorly planned thing and I'm importantly
planned in the sense that they announced
in advance or it was leaked in advance
then they put up a video so it pulled
all the wind out of their sales a bunch
will probably say okay I don't need to
watch it thanks I already know He
already announced then they had the
problems on the stream itself it's you
know what I think I think they're
sitting in their planning room and
someone goes what if we we announced on
Twitter with Elon oh that's a really
good idea let's do it and you know I was
like sure okay and then they didn't no
planning no planning No Tag no no uh no
program you got to think about what
happens before you got to think about
what happens don't got to think about
what happens after when we do shows like
this let me tell you my friends we have
I believe four different internet
systems I'm not gonna say too much more
than that for security reason but we
have backups upon backups upon backups
now people have pointed out they're like
Tim your shows have had problems before
in the past uh yeah technical issues do
happen we've had our backups fail we've
had weird technical glitches no problem
we are not running for president yeah no
and when there is 100 million dollars
we don't need billions of dollars we're
doing a YouTube we're doing an internet
livestream show on YouTube well there
there are backups for this live stream
show and when I do finally formally
announce my candidacy for president of
the United States we're going to make
sure the infrastructure is in place so
that it doesn't cut out or crash
someone someone said that he did take
authenticity training let me let me
double check that is that true someone
said he should have gone to Alex Stein's
show he failed seriously if he went on
on Alex Stein or or Glenn Beck
it would have been way bigger
I mean my biggest takeaway from this
whole thing is exactly I think what the
natural which is like how is Rhonda
santis going to be able to hold up
throughout this race with Donald Trump
and he's just gonna and what's what's so
sad about this which I think really the
undertones of everything is is that I
think everybody wants Ron DeSantis to
succeed yep I think I think everybody
wants Ron DeSantis no to be around in
2028 and 2032
and and to learn from it and to and to
pull from the base and listen to the
bass and listen to the Grassroots
but what everything that's that this is
looking like is that it's the opposite
no I I don't care who it is I want the
person that's going to go into the
government and harm the bureaucracy as
much as possible I don't want someone
that knows the ropes or whatever I don't
care what they know I want them to know
that they're cutting bureaucracy that
they're getting I wanted to get rid of
cabinet level bureaucracies cut them get
rid of the entire Department of
Education like like make real substance
substantial cuts and if DeSantis is
going to be like well we'll go in and
we'll go ahead and we'll change some
people around no not good enough for me
I want Cuts I want serious hacking with
a machete to the federal government but
I don't I don't know that Rhonda that
Donald Trump will do that either
necessarily but I do think he'll get
revenge on the bureaucrats so I I don't
know what Rich bear said but I did find
a tweet from David Marcus who said this
is the most embarrassing thing that has
ever happened to a presidential
candidate it's not close just hold a
rally
yeah man all right well let's move on or
do this yeah seriously just could have
done this like do a massive rally it's
like oh my gosh this is like Trump
here's here's the reality if they did it
on Rumble I think it would have been a
lot bigger but probably still would have
crashed not trying to be mean we use
Rumble infrastructure but it this is a
heavy undertaking if they just did on a
YouTube show they would have been the
official social media launch instead but
let's uh let's jump to the story from
the daily The Daily Beast and uh you'll
get a little bit more positive I guess
Target removes Pride merch after right
wing media throws hissy fit you see what
they called so uh targets being
boycotted they announced they're going
to be removing their uh a lot of their
pride section hiding a lot of it but the
CEO then says don't worry we're going to
keep our commitment up what they're
basically saying is regular people have
come in and expressed disdain so then to
hide these products but publicly into
the world they're gonna make sure
everybody knows they're still doing it
now this is hilarious Gavin Newsom
tweeted this isn't just a couple stores
in the South there's a systematic attack
on the gay community happening across
the country wake up America this doesn't
stop here you're black you're Asian
you're Jewish you're a woman you're next
so I would just like for everyone to
consider very briefly what gavinism just
said that Target will remove all of
their women's clothing because they
because their patriarchal or something
women can no you can't ShopRite your
target is only for men now well Tim I
mean it makes perfect sense right I mean
there's nothing that people who don't
want sexual perversion forced under
their children hate more than
Asians did The Daily Beast did The Daily
Beast have consider it freaking out when
uh when you had to go to the Supreme
Court to decide if a man could say no I
don't want to endorse your your marriage
of course The Daily Beast didn't freak
out of that but this is this is what
Kevin everything dude was that freaking
out like they said they say Republicans
are freaking out like this isn't the guy
to the Supreme Court that's was that was
that a history well hold on if it's a
hissy fit if it's a hissy fit uh then is
it not also a hissy fit to say oh you
don't want sexual perversion forced
under your child you must hate Asians
and black people you must hate minority
like what are you talking about the
history on Earth are you talking about
it was a couple weeks ago in Nashville
when a trans person went and killed a
bunch of Christians right that's the
hissy fit give me a goddamn break no it
was a hissy fit when they were burning
down Minneapolis remember and store
owners were like oh my gosh how am I
ever going to rebuild and they were
called that a hissy fit yes yes
infuriated this is all a big you know
charade of of calling you know calling
us out for when we get upset but the
reality is this is that they've learned
from the Bud Light thing so no I think I
think something happened they said there
were confrontations I think regular
parents that we we don't know these
stories I don't think there's videos I
think regular people walked in and saw
the weird sexualized stuff for kids and
said hey uh what are you doing I'm not
bringing my kids here and so the left
keeps trying to argue that none of this
is inherently sexual when quite
literally LGBT is a reference to a
person's sexual proclivities literally
so when they put that in a display with
children's clothing on it expressing
these ideas
if if imagine if they had a bondage
section for for kids
they're identical these things right
some someone both their perversions both
are sick perversions well I'm not I'm
not saying that you can say that what
I'm saying is there's a difference but
they're both sexual sexually themed
things that in and of themselves don't
directly Show sex what I mean to say is
telling someone that someone is gay
they're gonna ask a question okay well
then what does that mean it's like okay
well now we're gonna get into the birds
and the bees sure showing someone
bondage gear you say this is just chains
and and silly clothing but what is it
for okay now we're gonna talk about the
birds and the bees actually we're
talking about Kink so in some ways a lot
worse imagine if they put
put items on display which were intended
for use in a sexual context that you
know what I mean like the parents would
be like no that's what the left is
trying to lie about they're saying it's
not inherently sexual then when parent
like we've seen the videos from prod
where the guys wearing The Bugs Bunny
mask and jumping around naked like come
on man well here's the thing if it
wasn't inherently sexual they wouldn't
be so obsessed with trying to force it
onto children and they wouldn't lose
their minds when adults push back
against it because the thing they claim
is being attacked is their sexuality
yeah so here's what I think if this
wasn't sexual it wouldn't be the hill
they were dying on here's what I think
happens I think regular people walk into
Target see it and go kids no we're
leaving yeah like whoa whoa whoa whoa
well here's what here's what really I
was thinking about this today about the
whole thing remember the days when we
just got upset that they were putting
Christmas stuff out like right after
Halloween yeah and now it's like I mean
I don't even know what is lgbtq month
apparently it's June so this is why it's
out it's coming up guys it's not even
June so they're doing they're doing the
same old it's like
well Jade is actually American greatness
month yeah it's actually the month of
the Sacred Heart uh and then July is
Maga month yeah right yeah but this I
mean this is what's so crazy it's like
you're seeing this
and I I think I think it's mind-blowing
to me that people who can't have kids
you know want to exploit
all of the lgbtq community two kids it
like it doesn't even make sense to me
bizarre I think they cross the line I
think these corporations they've reached
the point where regular people are just
saying we are not accepting of this we
don't care if you're privately in your
own home we don't care if you want to
live your life and be happy but you
started putting a prominent display in
front of our children we started having
people do sexual things in the streets
at these at these Pride parades which
they do you had uh and I think it was in
Florida they said you can't have
grooming you can't have adult shows for
children so one town canceled their
pride parade what were they intending to
show kids at these Pride parades but but
why are they so obsessed with kids
I mean a lot of a lot I mean they're
they're just saying they're saying the
quiet part very loudly exactly what's
happening they have no interest in like
there's a whole this play of like oh
we're just trying to open up the eyes of
children that we don't want to have like
the vast majority of any gay couple that
exists doesn't have kids they have no
interest at all and so this isn't a
lifestyle this isn't a simple lifestyle
conversation this is literal straight up
perversion just trying to take advantage
of but but the main point here that I
want to make sure we're on is the
victory of the boycotts yeah that Bud
Light is reeling and they're not getting
these sales back bud guy was but Bud
Light was trending today to an absurd
degree yep I mean it was hundreds of
thousands of tweets over Bud Light and
their stock has dropped again the stock
for Bud Light is now lower than when it
started this year so there was a period
where I was like it'll go down but it'll
probably go up because all stocks to
typically climb but the the backlash is
getting worse for Bud Light now you've
got North space doing something similar
but they've been doing this for a while
the fact that North Face is on their I
think it's our second year doing this
drag promotion and now people are
getting angry and I'm like I think the
camel's back broke I think regular
people for a long time said we'll
tolerate it but we don't like it and
then one day they walk their kids into a
Target and saw this stuff and got angry
and they said that's it no none of it
none of it at all yeah well it's
somebody who's explaining the whole
distribution thing to me that part of
the reason why they're seeing the the
spike now with Bud Light is that the
Distributors finally have it's a wave
yeah they've or they've got the max it's
just all sitting there and they're like
no more finally so it's a lagging effect
here the first thing that happens is
that consumers stop buying and then
Distributors don't reorder but if some
of the beer expires they may reorder
yeah now they've got stacks of expired
beer Bud Lights offered to buy it back
yeah they said they will buy back the
expired beer from these Distributors
which is crazy because while the
distributor buy new ones yeah the
distributor is like I'm not I'm not
gonna just have it sit and take up space
it'll go bad again I'm not getting my
money back so you can have it but I am
buying more so it's a delayed reaction
eventually it makes it to the
Distributors who say we're not buying it
and then Bud Light sales get way bad so
Target who knows maybe they won't put
out Christmas stuff at after Halloween I
mean it's it's difficult holiday stuff
sure some people have a holiday gear
some you know when it comes to beer you
buy beer frequently if you drink beer
and there's not really strong brand
loyalty so it was the perfect boycott
Target some places only have Target if
you you live in some suburbs you have
nowhere else to go Target's your place
yeah if you can however avoid it I
recommend you avoid it and you're
breaking you know these habits of like
my wife you know ends up in Target four
times a week and it's like now you gotta
break that habit so you know kind of Geo
Tracker and I don't know shut down the
car or something I mean look look I
don't I don't care
if there are people who say
who save nowhere else to go I'm I I'm
not going to cry that they go to Target
it's not the same thing as Best Buy so I
think the fact that that targets I'm
sorry as a Bud Light I said Best Buy
I think the fact that they've already
decided to start taking things down
shows that they got impacted outside of
any real conservative boycott I think
regular people started complaining well
someone brought this up today too is
like you know the Target Card you know a
lot of again a lot of wives have a
Target card that's their credit card of
choice you know just go with your wife
and shut down the Target card that's
your first step instead of say hey we're
gonna shut down the Target card tonight
should shut down the Target Card Target
cart the card the card the credit card
yeah oh yeah just get rid of it shut
down your Target card
get that done tonight you can do that in
two seconds just pay it off say I'm
gonna pay it off I'm gonna get you a new
credit card it's gonna be a beautiful
credit card what about Walmart are they
what are they woke
uh I'm not so I think that the the
founders of the errors were Christian
but I have no idea if that if they're
still you know somebody was mentioning a
good organization I don't know they
found some stuff in Walmart too there
were some posts but they were just kind
of ducking and getting it off the
shelves real quick it was books I think
uh yeah it wouldn't shock me I mean it's
it's also swampy these days but
Walmart's really good about like
really blending with the with the local
community so I'm sure it's more liberal
and more liberal communities and way
more conservative so they'll have like
Christian books that front and like you
know I know in Utah yeah they have
Mormon books up front like I I bet my
guess is it's probably a little bit more
Liberal Liberal communities targets just
like they they push everything the same
yeah interesting so I uh I I just saw
this uh someone from The New York Times
is reporting that when DeSantis was on
with uh Trey Gowdy he finished it up uh
talking about the Federal Reserve and
that he was talking about the Jerome
Powell and as part of his campaign he
intends to blame the fed money printing
for laying groundwork for inflation
which is I mean that should be obvious
and any president that doesn't lay that
out is suspect I mean I I don't know
that Trump would he might sit there and
continue to uh to boast about all the
money printing which is a terrible idea
in my opinion but I personally I find
things that are you know criticism of
the the current monetary policy
compelling personally so
DC Drano hosted a live right now our
Twitter space and and uh it's been going
it's been going 50 000 strong for like
like I don't know a long time I don't
know if it's like an hour 55 000 hasn't
dropped at all
so
that's for Target I mean go to Walmart
it's the same thing yeah
just less Connecticut
why are they in Connecticut no no it's
just a Target like Target is to me
Target is what Walmart is it just be
like but for the Connecticut version
Connecticut's nose in the air kind of
Southern Connecticut although the
wealthy people well let's jump to the
store we got more good news for
everybody black lives matter Teeters on
the brink of insolvency after an 8.5
million dollar loss in 2022. you know
they made something like I think 77
million dollars in 2021 or something
like that so blm's near insolvency in
food racism stock is going to be through
the roof yeah yeah they uh only raised
9.3 million in 2022 down from 77 million
and 21 and 90 million in 2020. they're
going to spend the next year that is a
massive collapse you're gonna spend the
next year uh advocating Donald Trump to
get the uh to get the race the racism up
they say uh Patrice Culler resigned as
executive director in May 2021 did the
public learned she spent 3.2 million on
four separate homes on top of other
lavish expenses prior to a resignation
she was accused of funneling 230
thousand dollars to a company that
belonged to the father of her child well
there's a bunch of nepotism going on in
here but uh hey man look this is this is
good news right people aren't donating
anymore this is a lot moving into a 2024
election cycle
if they had 90 million in 2020 and then
two years later they're down to they're
down by 90 percent
that means the sentiment among regular
people is not favorable for black lives
matter and it means that many of these
people may be waking up or may just be
like we're out of this we're not going
to be involved in Corporate America
right because they got a lot from
Corporate America
which is really important in in this
case is like the the flip around on this
with corporate America is really
important for the future of the country
and and maybe maybe there's some hope
there I don't have a lot of Hope for
Corporate America but maybe there's a
little bit of things like ESG so there
was difficult there's the spirit if we
pull this up on Civics you can see that
around uh in 2019 there was a flip the
majority of people now started to
support black lives matter after uh
George Floyd died at spite at 52 percent
but now
43 oppose 41 support
and among independent voters
45 oppose and it seems relatively stable
but it spiked a great deal and that's
the riots
the rioting made independent voters say
you know what I do not support this
group which is really great news for the
Republicans how many people lied because
they were afraid they'd be called racist
for saying they don't support black
lives matter yep do you know the history
of black lives matter where it came from
Trayvon Martin
so yeah when it actually got its start
with student government in Missouri
so when the whole thing happened in
Missouri way back what thing in Missouri
Ferguson Ferguson all right and there
was a student government a student body
president here's a young black man uh
they started a campaign basically using
student government funds it was just
like because they have slush funds at
all these big universities and that's
where the the name black lives matter
came from uh it started well before that
and he got picked up by yeah started
with Trayvon Martin protests in New York
City I think pretty sure so the the
Ferguson stuff was a couple years later
but they but they basically turned it
into like a a movement that they funded
across all of the different universities
the student governments and then that
ended that kid in this white house with
Barack Obama his name was Peyton head
when did Patrice get involved This was
later so then they formalized that as an
organization but it's still the the tiny
legs that it had were funded essentially
through Student Government which was a
really interesting
tidbit which is a really important
reason why you can't let these
these universities just kind of run
rampant with this thing
yeah I remember in 28 roughly 2013 when
I first heard it 2014 when I first heard
it it was definitely Trayvon Martin at
least that's what gave it legs on the
Nationals yeah it started July 2013 with
the use of the hashtag black lives
matter on social media after the
acquittal of George Zimmerman yeah
because I remember I was down there in
New York when I was covering those
protests when all that went down and
that was the uh that was the beginning
and then there was some other guy who
created something called black lives
matter I think before all of them and
they they like shut his hijacked at all
yeah they stole it from him but uh but
they put but the money that got behind
it was originally from just like they
latched on to it identified it and said
this is something and so they took a
bunch of student government money which
is they were able to do across the
country landed at the White House
solidified it
I think for Democrats they're like oh we
can get votes from this totally let's
play that game this is this is a lot
about the current state of of politics
in this country though if BLM is
officially not in anymore
they're not people aren't donating so
that's it we're gonna we're gonna be
moving into a new era I think I'm fairly
optimistic especially with shows like
this on the rise with uh I mean look at
Tucker Carlson goes um independent
launching his own network or his own
online channels the rise of Rumble Elon
Musk buying Twitter I think it's all
looking fairly positive yeah they can't
shut things down last minute on us yeah
it's cool yeah there's hope yep no I
mean it's it's sitting you have to be
remarkably financially irresponsible to
mess a grift like that up you are the
face of give me money if you're Against
Racism anyone in Corporate America who
wants to be seen as virtuously
contributing to the anti-racist cause
has to give money to me how did you go
broke how how did you go broke well they
were spending a lot of questionable sums
of money yeah exactly hiring family
members
their cause is a scam anyway yep well
exactly right because there's never
going to be any end point for them
Patrice at what point I got maybe come
on at what point was BLM going to say
all right we solved racism
and I will clarify that statement anyway
I am saying the idea that is pro that
has perpetrated uh that there you know
what did that kid say 30 of black people
are killed every year yeah these ideas
of this Mass systemic inequality is just
completely untrue is there racism yes is
there racism in government there is are
there racist people yes there are to the
degree that they've brought it up it's
not true George Zimmerman was a Hispanic
Hispanic guy so this whole idea is
launched off of this
idea of of racism from white people and
it's like you mean when that Hispanic
guy fought with that kid like what are
you talking about yeah or when Michael
Brown it's confirmed by the the Eric
Holder AG that he did not have his hands
up and fought the cop
like we get it man you know like we
don't want innocent people dying
especially based on race but the the pr
the premise of what you're donating to
doesn't make sense but hey I don't know
what they do with it they're getting
they're getting flacked because they
bought this big house yeah but if they
bought a house to do a studio or
something what are you gonna complain
about I don't think anybody who donated
to BLM is crying about it right now one
some people maybe but most people are
probably fine they don't let it donated
1.5 million dollars went to patrice's
Brother for security yeah well I think
five years for security and then you got
to ask and so there are there are
questions about they said they didn't
want to do traditional security or
police because the distrust around
policing but people think these sums of
money means he wrote a check for a two
million like a million and a half bucks
to a guy and then he bought it for
Ferrari no no this could have been
licensing equipment Staffing right so
she also gave a guy 970 000 for Live
Events or the organization gave Live
Events and everyone's like oh that dude
probably didn't see that money right
organizing Live Events is very very
expensive offensive I just want to
mention something because Tim you said
that you know the people who donated to
BLM probably aren't too upset I just
want to let everyone in this room know
that we've all donated to BLM because JB
pritzker gave 300 000 in federal covid
relief money to BLM well I mean if you
live here but no it was Federal covid
relief money right right yeah from the
federal government they said and and
pritzker said you know what you know how
we're going to relieve people of covet
giving money to BLM okay thank you I can
tell you at Turning Point running a
large non-profit that you know we have a
very blessed to raise a lot of money
we've hired and Staffing we've staffed
thousands of people over the years right
like we have right now on staff hundreds
and hundreds of people between our
organization
building that within a year you know
where did all that money go is a really
great question because I mean we're not
talking about 10 million dollars we're
not talking about 15 million we're
talking about literally they were and
they had transactionally hundreds of
millions of dollars that they had access
to essentially in in capital that they
worked with
where did all the money go
that's a great question right because
they didn't where all the staff where's
the BLM staff I know what it costs to
put on a massive live event I know what
it cost to put on these huge things they
didn't do any of that so you know what
we know of is just a very small sliver
of what really bad things they probably
did actually happen because you don't
know these things when C3 C4s they file
this way I don't even I'm not even
convinced BLM did anything untoward in a
certain sense you give them money they
can do what they want with they just
couldn't build there's no way you can
build a 100 million dollar organization
in basically a year or two years they've
been around what they had to do but I
mean they they the same people were
involved since 2013. right but they they
but they built the actual organization
within like a year after getting all
that money because they were they were
just taking in money based off of the
news and the climate and from Corporate
America like they just didn't have the
capability of actually building this
thing so it's not a surprise that
they've completely failed
yeah no but I think that the important
takeaway as I mentioned earlier is
whatever it is that's resulting in
people not wanting to give BLM money is
going to have a similar rollover effect
on everything else yeah and I think
there's a lot of people who are wising
up you know we were skating in uh in
Hagerstown I mentioned this the other
day and a bunch of local Suburban
Maryland people were like yo crime is
getting out of control what's going on
and then these people started talking
about gun ownership gun rights and I'm
like there it is 2A is going to be
stronger Trump's going to win and it's
because these suburbanite people are
tied to the violent crime and the cops
doing nothing about it yeah what do you
do though right if your neighborhood is
falling to crap eventually you have
nothing to do but just ask that question
yep
and then you end up voting for the right
guy
all roads lead to the same place when
you're you know when you have a action
the constitutional principles being
followed that's probably the reason why
they want to destroy all of it that's
why they want to subvert all this with
you know crazy stuff like you know I saw
some things on National popular vote not
to take us off but ranked Choice voting
this stuff is really scary because no
matter what the public sentiment is
they're trying to subvert whatever that
is that's that's the future that's what
we're up against right now in the United
States of America and they were winning
last 10 years I think there's bad stuff
going on but the bad stuff is just
accelerating regular people waking up
hopefully yeah hopefully let's uh let's
talk about Joe Biden's broken brain from
tipguest.com seven and ten Independents
are worried about Biden's mental Fitness
worried about how about convinced there
is none he doesn't have mental Fitness
they say a new poll has found that
nearly seven in ten registered
Independents are worried about President
Joe Biden's mental Fitness ahead of the
2024 election this is NPR PBS NewsHour
Marist published on Wednesday found that
69 percent of richer Independents
believe his mental Fitness is a genuine
concern while 27 believe is mental
Fitness is being used as a campaign
strategy by opponents I love this
because the way you frame a question
always matters if I were to ask the
average person do you think Joe Biden's
brain is broken about 70 say yes
if you were then ask them is it a
concern 70 say yes you see how they do
this
yeah
I can't imagine how people can have any
kind of awareness of the president and
not say Well it kind of you know
listen to him you know I mean that's
that's your standard kind of the reply
that you would expect from the average
person that doesn't pay a whole lot of
attention to to politics if you've only
got
you know if you dedicate 15 minutes a
day to watching a little bit of news so
that way you feel like you have an idea
about what people are talking about and
you hear Joe Biden
twice a week
you can't feel confident that this guy's
you know laser focused on what's going
on
I I can't imagine how that is and then
obviously it's showing in the in the
polls yeah I mean I I just don't know
how you could have seen Joe Biden say
anything in public and not be worried
about the status of his mental health
the best the best the man does at public
speaking is
slurring his words instead of constantly
gaffing I remember when we watched his
State of the Union Address about a year
and a half ago and it was probably the
best he'd sounded in the last year and a
half but he did sound drunk the entire
time I'm not saying he was drunk I'm
just saying his brain operates in such a
way
that when he speaks normally he slurs
his words to the point where he sounds
intoxicated I think that one of the one
of the negatives about the way that the
Twitter space went today is I don't see
a convincing
argument to get the president on a
Twitter space had this gone perfectly
and it been great and and had everything
worked fine then you could all then you
could argue okay we have to get the you
know get more presidential uh candidates
on the more you get the more pressure it
is on Trump and and Biden
um I would like to see that happen but I
feel like that was probably the biggest
uh the biggest negative about this is
the fact that it's it's it doesn't lend
credibility to Independent Media and
stuff the way that that I had hoped that
it would well Joe Biden would benefit
from this like FDR did there is no way
Joe Biden yeah
for an hour yeah but I mean this is like
I was thinking about this today what
greater you know this is the BLM
crossover here
what greater vision of white privilege
could possibly exist than the media and
everyone else covering for Joe Biden and
Hunter Biden like literally they've been
trying to indoctrinate our kids
they haven't tried all of society
basically on this false notion of white
privilege and you've got an old guy in
there that just wanders around stage
they run CR You Know cover for them the
entire time his son is like literally
the worst
presidential kid ever to exist in the
history yeah should be in jail for the
rest of his life and this isn't why
they're not talking about white
privilege now this is crazy it's a wild
thing he's like he's like the ultimate
nepo baby that's ever existed seriously
yeah and so is Joe Biden though Joe
Biden is benefiting from like the
nepotistic elements of media where like
they're covering for him because he
can't literally conduct himself in a
public setting it's crazy yeah Hunter
Biden is really a remarkable character
he is he is a caricature of what
Republicans suspected a democratic
President's child could get away with
like really smoking crack that sounds
like a joke yeah right the man got on
national television and said he has
spent more time picking through the
carpet for anything that even remotely
resembles crack cocaine that he smoked
more parmesan cheese than anyone you
know and that's not even talking about
his dad's mental health yeah his dad's
mental health should be disqualifying
and completely remember when uh Nancy
Pelosi Was preparing the 25th Amendment
committee or whatever and everyone's
like it's for Trump and then they went
wait no it's provided yeah yeah I mean
the man is but that's white privilege my
friends I mean the guy is getting away
with like like the the kill shot White
Privilege out of the left we should be
demanding they hold themselves
accountable to White Privilege at this
point since they spent so much time on
it just embrace the white privilege
narrative but focus on Joe bides just
focus on Joe Biden yeah just use it
against them to destroy it that could
help someone like the vague Rama Swami
but then those big but Trump's an old
white man too it's like all right well
then why don't you talk smack about both
of them yeah but but the real is the
left doesn't like Joe Biden anyway
Liberals are the ones who who vote for
him but I don't think anybody actually
likes him I think they're just like
we'll take any warm body over Donald
Trump
exclusively on this kind of stuff well
he's totally it's his campaign he's
totally opposed to it yeah so that's why
you should focus on it you should take
advantage of it yeah and be like I'm
going to win because you're going to
you're going to demand that I win and
then I'm going to change the laws and
take away the ability of this happen
again that'd be great in the meantime we
have to hope that Joe Biden doesn't
accidentally like press the button or
something right well I don't think well
yeah yeah that wouldn't even be that
much of a scandal they would try to spin
that too like it was a mostly peaceful
new King and I I bet kamela Harris is
the actual president
because he keeps calling her president
Kamala I think it's far more likely that
Barack Obama's phoning it in then Kamala
Harris is doing it
I I'm deathly scared you know being the
Arizona here I'm deathly afraid of
this concept of potentially Kirsten
Cinema replacing Kamala Harris
what do you mean
I just there's something really funny
going on in Arizona you mean like
yourself runs Cinema is going to be the
she doesn't have a real shot I don't
think right ready for Senate just like
the pathway is not there unless like
there's just like something that's
totally crazy
so it's like what is she doing like what
she has way too much money she's loved
by the Chamber of Commerce she's loved
by The Establishment Goons
uh I'm really afraid that they're gonna
just like do this like this the
switcheroo the swapparoo and involve her
in some way that because again you have
to look at the map you guys have talked
about it here you talked about with
Charlie which is part of what we talk
about it's Arizona Wisconsin Georgia is
everything yeah so like getting Arizona
taken care of basically takes the map
off the table for the Republican and
then people hate Harris they despise her
they put in a cinema and she's lukewarm
but a lot of people will be like okay
well Biden's incompetent but Cinemas you
know she's cool whatever right yeah and
then I wonder if you have to have a
DeSantis just because Trump I don't
think Trump can change his standing with
the American people no you either like
him or you don't some people are
probably for either for his policies or
they're not I think enough people would
be in favor of trump at this point but
he's got maximum name recognition
everybody knows and so if DeSantis is an
opportunity or something new I think he
kind of blew it today but I still think
he can recover yeah
yeah I mean there's a long a lot of time
left here but you know it's an eternity
it I mean at this point I heard someone
talking about it today at this point in
the 2008 campaign it was Rudy Giuliani
and Hillary Clinton that were obviously
going to be the uh the the people that
were Giuliani they thought that yeah at
this point this far out they were they
said that Giuliani and Clinton and no
one could figure out you know it was
like obvious and blah blah and then this
young senator from uh Illinois
popped his head up and and the whole
world changed so oh man Hillary was so
pissed yeah she was her turn I love it
and then Obama beat her yeah they didn't
have their ducks on a row at the DNC yep
well they still don't I guess
they don't have I don't know if anybody
actually in government has their ducks
and I'll be at you know the committees
or the Pacs or the campaigns the parties
it's all just insane nonsense well the
DNC will control controls the process
now after that happened
that's why Bernie came the DNC the DNC
has had their finger on the federal
government has has had their finger on
the the scale for the DNC definitely
since brocco or since uh since um Donald
Trump was elected like Donald Trump
beating Hillary Clinton was not supposed
to happen and after that then federal
government has had their finger on the
on the scale as much as they can they
have been they have been pumping out as
much propaganda to all of the the Legacy
Media uh establishments that they can
that they that will take it
um so the government looked at Donald
Trump and said this is a really bad
thing and it's been doing its best to
make sure that Donald Trump can't get
elected again so
well a lot of that comes down to the
unpreparedness that the Democrats had in
Michigan which again you want to bring
up things that will never happen again
they will never let Michigan
slide out of their hands again it would
take a whole lot it would take a massive
massive undertaking a massive Army for
us to win Michigan
yeah but is Michigan one of the
principal States we got to win 2024 it's
one of only six or seven that matter
yeah and you know you look at what they
did with with the election law Michigan
basically making it impossible for us to
overcome cheating there uh manipulation
you know not to get too far into the
weeds but I mean they spend you know
tens of millions of dollars on ballot
Chasey ballot harvesting and until the
right can match that you're not going to
get close enough to be able to even
think about overcoming you know the
manipulation that they do in those
States
all right let's go to super chats if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share this show with your
friends and become a member over at
timcast.com by clicking join us we're
gonna have a members only uncensored
show coming up for you at about 10 10
p.m you don't want to miss it but uh
we'll read your super chats for now we
got Max Dolly says head greater than
heart substance greater than sentiment
DeSantis 2024. it's a that's a great
slogan that will not play at all for the
average American who only really cares
about how you sound on stage it's
unfortunate but it's true so what we
need in a president is someone who is
clearly a charismatic leader who
understands the policies the position
the culture War
we're not trying to get the B team I
would take someone who's great with
policy over someone who just spoke well
any uh or any any day of the week
we need somebody who speaks well and
knows the policies so that we can win
as a leader
what do we got
purple says Twitter space low energy
basic answers
I agree very low energy
Raymond says I just want to know how you
could not call the pumpkin coffee hocus
bocus the spiced pumpkin Brew oh that's
good Mr boca's pumpkin spice experience
yeah focus with Mr bocus will be a
medium Rose I think that's what we're
working on all right
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim Sir Mr
pool I loved your North Face segment I
agree once they started targeting
children they ripped the fence out from
underneath us
there will be a recording for the line
yeah my point was basically this
I don't care if North Face wants to do a
drag queen promo I just won't buy North
Face but now that they've moved beyond
that into targeting kids I'm like no no
no no all of it none it's basically like
I put his way dude shows up to to your
party you don't know who he is and
you're like okay look I don't know this
guy but you know my friend brought him
over it's fine once the dude starts
going over little kids and trying to
sniff them we say get out get out get
out we were fine with you here but now
you're doing the weird kid stuff out of
the building go home
that's how I feel about it
yeah
where are we at
Dylan Binkley says on the show the other
night you brought up Governor gianforte
legally defining gender in the state of
Montana you should have rep Michelle
Binkley on and talk about Montana
politics more in depth love you Tim uh
sounds good are you Dylan Binkley
related to rep Michelle Binkley perhaps
we'll see
that's that's the kind of rizz energy
that uh DeSantis needs
get in there promoting his own family
you know there you go
Robert Bradbury says let's get let's go
Ronnie D take down the guy that tried to
violate 2A with the bump stock ban I
think he lost that one though the the
bump stock band thing yeah of course
they're illegal so oh wait no the court
court Struck it down I'm pretty sure you
might be right yeah end of the chick
it's just that the stores that sold them
no longer sell them already so it got
they did what they needed to do
Angela Richter says why would he phone
in his announcement it was horrible if I
were him I would say it was all a joke
and hide out yikes
yeah T-Rex patch up says DeSantis should
wait his turn he would be a great
president in 2028. what's the deal with
Carrie likes lawsuit does Tyler have any
pets we are an anti-woke alternative to
woke PetSmart Chewie and Petco
we've got pets yeah what's going on
Carrie Lake
well first off I have a Golden Retriever
and I have a wirefox terror but uh
they're both they're both Gilligan and
Skipper uh Carey lake so uh just talked
to Carrie's team you know been been big
allies with Carrie throughout this
election you know she just you have to
understand the courts are not our friend
you're not gonna get We're not gonna get
where we want to go in a state like
Arizona where you have establishment
control for 50 years I mean we're
talking 50 years we're talking McCain
machine has installed all of these
judges judges work their way at the
ladder over the course of their entire
lifetime and so if you're expecting the
courts to be your friend in a place like
Arizona or Texas
it's just not going to happen
and so it's kind of it's kind of a
mistake it's a flawed strategy in my
opinion I just don't think it's gonna
result
um it's it's not it's not resulting for
carry we know that they did a lot of
wrong things and unfortunately we don't
have attorneys we don't have a legion of
attorneys who are going to step up
they're going to basically they have the
intestinal fortitude to fight the good
fight until losing their law license
like the left hat and that's where we're
at right now Across America that's just
not an Arizona thing that's across
America so you know we're gonna have to
take some significant strategy here and
I think this is part of you know I'm on
the RNC
the RNC I've been very vocal about this
has not done its job with producing the
hundred plus attorneys that we need that
can go fight the good fight against our
and build our own Perkins coin we just
don't have it
all right Matt Burkhart says all these
Trump supporters roasting Ron are
actively pushing for Democrat wins for
years Trump will lose to Biden again
killing Ron's momentum will leave ours
with nobody else
we are telling you Ron DeSantis lacks
the Charisma to win it doesn't matter
what anyone else says it doesn't matter
what Trump supporters say I I'm telling
you you can't have a guy get up on stage
and say truth matters and freedom is
worth fighting for because people are
gonna be like what's he talking about
you got you you got to get there and go
the truth matters in this country you've
got to have some emotion all right maybe
not Trump but you got to say listen in
this country truth matters and freedom
is worth fighting for that's why I'm
here
he can't even do that well and I'll say
this I have no idea I mean maybe
DeSantis could win with his current
level of Charisma I'm not making any
predictions about the future but what I
will say is if you really like a
candidate and you want to help make him
stronger constructive criticism is an
important part of that and what I am
saying and what I've said repeatedly is
I like DeSantis I like a lot of what the
scientist has done through his entire
political career even before covet I
found him interesting and like the
things that he said however
that doesn't mean he's perfect and one
of his flaws is a pretty major flaw
which is that when he speaks it's not
all that engaging we can say that to him
with the hopes of him working that out
in a way that makes him more electable
without being against him in fact quite
to the contrary we want him to improve
as a candidate that's why we're saying
this at least that's why I'm saying this
I don't I want I want DeSantis to be as
successful as DeSantis can be and I
think that pretending that he doesn't
have a Charisma problem isn't going to
help him how do you practice Charisma
how do you get better at it I don't know
but I do know that there's a reason that
political leaders will spend obscene
amounts of money with people who coach
them to try to become more charismatic
and I would suspect that's because they
see results there are channels on
YouTube
yeah like I'm not trying to be so harsh
on on DeSantis I guess my point is just
I the thing is why I find myself loving
so much of what he says is really great
like I like what he says and I like a
lot of what he's done I think he's been
one of the few Republican leaders that
we've seen in the past decade he's been
one of the best Republican leaders we've
seen in the past decade and I think that
it is a shame that that message is going
to be lost on so many people because
there are people who support him and
around him who are invested and not
having him here anything that will cause
him to want to improve his delivery I
would want to push back on that a little
bit because I don't feel like he says
anything that's new I don't think that I
totally disagree you think that he says
new things well I mentioned this earlier
where he was on covid was so far outside
of the status quo that at the time it
was very much a new thing now because he
was clearly on the right side of that
issue he's at the disadvantage of being
so correct so soon where it doesn't even
seem like an interesting position
anymore but I think that's a good thing
it means he moved the goal post in the
right direction hey even Michael Scott
took improv classes so like like Ron
DeSantis probably needs to take a few
improv classes realize like you can be
funny without being funny meaning to be
funny which is like Trump does a lot of
that right like he's just funny he's
just a funny guy he gets up and starts
talking and improving his speeches and
people are like I like that guy he's
kind of funny he's kind of normal he's
like weird like my uncle or like my my
grandpa or whatever yeah but you can
also be funny like Reagan was funny
where it's like he was he took classes
he was classically trained he was an
actor right like he was an actor it's
even like regular like speech like I
feel like even when I just speak to
people in general just normally talking
to them I have more inflection and more
character he just like it just seemed
flat and monotone like he was reading
like like right off prompter and that I
don't know that doesn't really sit well
with me or most Americans these days you
know I just don't have any kind of
particular allegiance to Ron DeSantis I
know that there are people out there
that are like you know he would be more
electable than Trump Etc and I I don't
think so because
even if he were to take the uh the
nomination the entire establishment and
all of the propaganda that comes along
with it is going to be turned against
him and they're going to demonize him in
the exact same way that they did Trump
the the
all of the pieces are in place to make
Ron DeSantis worse than Donald Trump
they've already started saying those
things I think Bill Crystal called them
a beta he called Trump an alpha like
what was that even that was kind of
weird that's like some weird like what
is he some like 30 year old guy with a
podcast in the nanosphere this guy's a
beta don't give me that everybody's bank
account noticed a significant uh
decrease without Donald Trump in office
and that's all it is yeah yeah yeah but
you know it's also personality like
people watch your show because they're
just like look
I like that person I like that vibe that
he puts out and it's consistent and it's
and there's there's a normalcy to it
that like people just have uh like
normal quirks about them when you have a
politician that isn't quirky that
doesn't have things that you can see and
you can follow and you can get every
time that you you turn on the TV
basically
people start to lose interest and that's
the world that we're in today totally
especially in a post-trump world is
there like I turn on the TV because even
I don't like Trump
he's hilarious and he's quirky and he's
weird and I'm gonna get something out of
it
tripwire says don't get me wrong I love
what DeSantis has been doing in Florida
but he did say if Trump ran in 2024 he
wouldn't his campaign is to be uh his
campaign to be is founded on a lie makes
me now wonder if all all has done was
just pretense to run for POTUS
yep
yeah a lot of people were like he's just
throwing you red meat he's telling you
what you want to hear that way he gets
elected and then it's neocon City all
over again I'm not saying I believe it
to be true because he actually did these
things in Florida so you know we got
what we wanted we got everything
I just don't think he has the Charisma
but Trump cleared a lane for him in
Florida like I I think that all the
missiles were directed at Trump and
Mar-A-Lago and Florida where it's like
it's really alleviated and created a
pathway for Ron DeSantis and again the
unwinnable subject matter here Florida
for Democrats has allowed it to to cut
cut off here
oh I'm sorry yeah
oh God I I was I was going to say this
last point is the Democrats pulled out
of Florida in 2022. like let's be let's
be real all of the groups the big groups
that are over the top of the DNC they
pulled out of Florida
and part of that is Trump and some of
it's DeSantis but a large portion of
this is Trump
gormall's uh gorm gorm male gormall
DeSantis won't last 10 seconds against
the corrupt Democrat Party they're going
to eat him alive
well and this is something that people
are saying it's like well you know Joe
Biden wasn't very charismatic why would
DeSantis need to be charismatic I think
we can all agree without even having to
get into too much detail that Biden had
certain unfair advantages that DeSantis
is not going to have the entire dominant
media culture was on his side they
literally published an article saying
this is how we coalesce to ensure that
this guy would get elected no one's
going to do that for DeSantis they're
going to work against DeSantis
yep they said stay alive Joe Biden all
we need is your corporeal form yeah
that's right and also like I want to
make it really clear I am not making any
election or any predictions about the
election or who's more electable or how
it's going to pan out I am just saying
it doesn't hurt anyone for DeSantis to
become more charismatic it does not hurt
anyone and it can become it could be
massively uh instrumental in ensuring
that his message is heard and taken
seriously by a larger percentage of the
American population Eric Cecil says
pretty ironic you're criticizing Elon
and DeSantis for a few glitches on
Twitter on a Twitter space when you
couldn't even set up audio at a bar in
Austin Texas for the entire event also
Trump can't beat Biden to Santa's will
you weren't running I think I think it's
pretty funny that um
comparing a
um like 12-way microphone setup because
it wasn't just people on stage with
multiple cameras and a sound system for
a live event and live stream comparing
that to three guys sitting in a room
with their phone sitting in front of
them is remarkable if we were going to
do Tim guest IRL on Twitter spaces I'd
put the phone right in front of me and
I'd press play and then we talk that's
it now I I understand there are issues
with the the entirety of the Twitter
infrastructure and what it can handle
that's fine but the fact that Elon
unmuted his microphone while the guy
sitting next to him was speaking causing
a feedback loop and then the guy mutes
his his account mid-speech those those
are human errors and like James said
we're not running for president our
budget for this thing was like was like
20 or 30 I think it was like 30 000
we're not launching a multi-billion
dollar presidential campaign yeah but
you know what you're still I'll still
give you credit we should have better
audio
is running for president and what did we
get this Placid announcement phoned in
it's remarkable no event no peep like no
video that's because people are around
him are telling them be more boring
they're telling him to do that
because of because of trump being too
bombastic yeah but again I think the uh
the the real Optics of this is Trump
needs to be more boring right but Ron
DeSantis needs to be more vivacious yeah
I guess I'm gonna have to run you know
because I'm I'm I I'm the only person I
believe can do it right now I would
never go anywhere near that I think
Trump's the guy right now Trump's the
guy who's gonna go and just fire
everybody yeah I'm I'm not as there's no
guarantee he does we may look back on on
an episode like this and be like man
were we wrong Trump brought the swamp
back or something like that who knows
but our best bet in my mind based on the
data available as of this date May 24th
and 23 is that Trump is the guy who's
most likely to Biden's is going to
hire more DeSantis may but probably
probably will negotiate Trump fires
yeah
I hope
no says please someone bottle this it's
better than melatonin well yeah you know
uh tonight after the show I'm gonna play
desantis's uh announcement speech to so
I get to bed early
that's for sure yeah it didn't hype
things up ahead of time I was really I
was really hoping that we'd go into this
whole thing with a really big hype story
with this and it was a snooze Fest
calisthenics Earth says he would have
been much better off just announcing it
on an interview with John Stossel have
it released with the full interview
being dropped uh that dropped yesterday
seriously yeah he could have just made a
Twitter video and it would have been a
better launch where he's like hi I'm
announcing I'm running for president
because truth matters hey at least Sean
Stossel has that like Dateline
over-the-top voice you know yes that's
what's good exciting good dude
Michael page says Ron de Sandman oh boy
here come the means memes Jon Jones says
Ron deserver crashed
was it a clintus says who are Ron
DeSantis donors
who are they I mean Ken Griffith
Griffin yeah big one
said what does it say saddle effing
says Santa's campaign announcement
was making his appeal to a jury not a
mom he needs to appeal to a mob like
trumpkin um
if they're really telling him to be
boring man this will be the shortest
campaign ever they'll spiral out because
people are not you can't keep people's
attention yeah part of what helped Trump
win was the negative press his name
constantly being in the media no matter
what
MSNBC gave him what like a billion
dollars worth of time CNBC gave him I
think five billion equivalent they
reported and just saying his name
Non-Stop
Aaron says give me the vague ramaswamy
bring policy and delivery
seriously he's great yeah
Jake says it's incredibly ironic that is
Santa's colors Biden's vaccinated is
unconstitutional but went out of his way
to preserve Florida's law allowing
police officers to forcibly vaccinate
civilians that doesn't sound real
do they have that
that's crazy
the great anywho says he has the perfect
lawyer voice hmm
I don't like hearing from lawyers yeah
yeah he does
and espo says I don't understand is it
Trump or nothing DeSantis was the first
yes politician that saved my job the
first yes no other politician including
Trump did that focus on policy not
fanfare
spoken like someone who is smart but not
good with people
so many Republicans have that logic but
no feeling no emotion and they don't get
it Democrats know emotion is everything
they invest in it and Republicans are
like logic Republicans are the ones who
are going to go on be like if you vote
for me I'll explain to you in this
three-point plan how we bring back jobs
to your to your neighborhood now the big
thing you're facing is over taxation
which drives Court when they're going
huh then you get Barack Obama go can't
we do it yes we can ah those are
screaming that's all he says can we do
it yes we can they vote for him
literally Bob the Builder I'll say this
too I mean again this this hopefully I
made myself clear about this I'm not
making a claim about whether Trump is
necessarily going to be better in the
general election what I am saying is
with DeSantis level of Charisma it's not
helping his chances I don't I just don't
know how you could argue that him
working on his delivery is a bad idea or
a bad suggestion I mean he really needs
help there you can't deny that you
really can't deny it it doesn't help him
that's why I'm harping on it man if I
wanted to make you all feel great I'd go
oh I apologize I shouldn't have said no
dude it's it's true like in desantises
people need to know that that's
something for him to work on I want him
to be successful I don't think he's
going to be as successful as he can be
if that isn't worked out
one thing to point out is that Florida
has a a moderately early primary I mean
it's like I think it's like smack in the
middle it's in mid-march but like if
DeSantis doesn't win Florida that's
going to be like
if it's looking like we're coming up to
Florida and he doesn't have a chance to
win Florida that is a huge problem
that's a huge problem for Rhonda santis
too and so we'll see where the polls end
up in Florida but
all right so gono says TDS goes both
ways it seems I don't care how electric
a politician is I care if they deliver
the results they promise which is what
we have seen repeatedly from DeSantis I
like Trump but there is no loyalty to
politicians
yep and can the politician get elected
electability matters you can have the
best policies in the world or you can
take Trump who's got a lot of good
policies and has the demeanor and the
character uh I'm not saying Trump is
perfect not by any stretch but dude The
Economist says Rhonda snooze Fest no I
showed so I showed some some people and
they went wow like it was just reading a
piece of paper like not even feeling it
it just felt so dry so I mean it's just
flat it's just flat
flats and unders understatement it's
concave yeah totally
yeah I mean but I just wanna like if if
you're a die-hard DeSantis supporter if
you're a never Trumper you really think
DeSantis has to be the guy don't you
want him to work on that don't you want
him to get better at his delivery so he
can be more successful I don't
understand this why would you pretend
that there isn't a problem there totally
is because when you fundamentally
believe that trumpism is bad and the way
that Trump captivated his audience is
bad you want you want the opposite
that's that's actually at its heart part
of the problem for DeSantis
I think yeah
Seymour Bud says Tim we don't want an
elitist Blue Falcon who graduated from
two ivy league law schools then went to
where the Blue Falcon title Blue Falcon
yeah well Trump also graduated from
elitist yeah
so and I mean yeah true ivy league Ian
says sorry late to the party but I
didn't see where DeSantis addressed
Trump his biggest competition he came
out too weak I appreciate him trying to
be seemingly drama-free but he is
playing it's too safe in my opinion
yup vanilla yogurt
Guardsman Norm says that sand has rolled
a politician with high wisdom but used
Charisma as a dumpster
Ian would appreciate that one if he was
here I like DND
Robert Kolling says if you want Charisma
look at Lieutenant Governor Mark
Robinson in North Carolina he knocks it
out of the park
who's is he the guy who was singing with
John rich
who is that I don't know
was that the guy
not sure
foreign
as an eight-year viewer you have TDS
dude Trump can't describe CRT and Dei
does that has explain to them
articularly and how he destroy them and
how he has in Florida you're simping for
Trump too hard oh go cry me a river dude
Barack Obama gets elected after blowing
up children because people don't care
about policy I would love it if Rhonda
Saida Scott got in an enacted policy
which I think he does better than Trump
but it's insane to think at the at the
current Pace he's gonna be able to do it
it's it's remarkable to me that someone
like me I pay attention to this stuff I
watch Obama get in office start blowing
up children immediately and I'm like wow
that's the opposite of what I voted for
and people are just like I'm gonna vote
for him again and I was like what about
blowing up kids do you think Warren's
re-election and they're like I don't
care because Barack Obama goes on TV
with a charming smile and says listen
we can do it and they go can't we do it
yes we can he didn't say anything
can we hope and change can we do it as
we can yeah Donald Trump wins make
America great again
Trump at least talked about building a
big beautiful wall from Cedar shining
sea Trump had some policies none of
these guys are perfect but Donald Trump
banned at the federal level Contracting
with corporations that had this woke
garbage in in in their companies he was
shutting it down in the military as well
I think Rhonda Sanders would do better
policy wise but we're talking about the
executive branch Rhonda said this would
not be a legislator when he's in the
executive branch he'd be president so he
can talk all day and not other things he
wants to do but he's not passing laws or
anything about it if anything he should
be running for Senate if that's the case
or or he should be vice president and be
president of the Senate that's a better
place for him to be Donald Trump is the
guy who's got the Brash attitude who I
want to see start enforcing some laws
not saying he will but dude you can sit
here and be like this is what really
bugs me about why the like about the
right why they lose too much when it
comes to this political stuff
Ben Shapiro comes out and says facts
don't care about your feelings and they
all start going waving their arms and
they're cheering for it and I'm like
that means nothing to the average person
who believes feelings don't care about
your facts yeah and that's why Democrats
win over the default liberal it should
be default conservative yeah it should
be when we look at the Bud Light stuff
it should be default that people are
like I'm not buying that because you
know I don't wanna I don't want to be
made fun of all my friends
the the Democrats use shame and fear the
powerful emotions to win elections
Republicans try convincing people now
that's that's Noble it's honorable good
luck you put Rhonda Sanders on a stage
you you I'll tell you this you take a
guy who sells medical equipment and put
him next to Rhonda santis and you will
believe in your mind that Ron knows
nothing about the politics and the and
the medical supply sales guy knows
everything because being able to speak
and being charismatic conveys more trust
than not being able to I have anything
from a lot of people when they say
things like
oh you know all this stuff and I'm like
what makes you think I actually know
something like well it sounds like you
know it yeah I read it on the news and
it could be a lie later on if a guy goes
on stage like Rhonda Sanderson says
freedom is worth fighting for you're
like don't sound like he actually thinks
that and then someone else comes up and
goes freedom is worth fighting for and
that's why you must join me people are
gonna be back oh that that's that's
definitive I've seen it happen at all
these different rallies I've seen the
left do it time after time I've seen
every non-profit pull this off if you
don't know
and if you don't sound convinced people
will not follow you end of story yeah
absolutely
um and I think anytime there's any
criticism made of DeSantis
people are going to assume because of
the Rivalry that what you're saying is
that you think that DeSantis is terrible
and Trump is great that's not
necessarily the case you could say look
DeSantis has this flaw that he needs to
work out it's going to make him more
electable and I think uh that super
chatter actually has uh the Trump
Arrangement syndrome because they're
they're they're so obsessed with getting
in anyone else they would take a guy who
probably probably would lose there was a
poll that came out I think it was a
interactive pulse post of this Trump uh
descent is losing to Biden by three
points now they're going to come out and
they're going to tell you no no we want
we want Trump to run you had on The View
they said we want Trump to be the
candidate so we can beat him they want
DeSantis to be the candidate because
he's dry because he's boring and
monotonous yeah yeah I like DeSantis I
think he would be a great president I
think his policies are excellent but in
order to be a leader you need more than
just good ideas Ronda Sanders the good
idea guy he's an advisor to the
president he's a vice president he's a
CEO he's a chief of staff he is not the
president the president is going to go
out and rally the American people around
these ideas DeSantis can be that guy but
I'm just so fed up I can't believe after
all this time we knew he was going to
run they did not give him legitimate
real training or Direction yeah well
insane yeah you're exactly right I hate
when people say you you hit spot on
facts don't care about your feelings
well yeah but people care about your
feelings people care about those
feelings that's a totally different
thing from winning an argument versus
influencing those around you people
don't people won't remember what's the
saying it's a people won't remember what
you say but they will remember how you
made them feel so when Donald Trump
makes you laugh you know what's going to
happen you associate that Trump rally
with having fun totally a good time when
someone goes on stage and just talks and
you're falling asleep you don't even
remember it yep yeah well like what did
you what did you have for breakfast
yesterday they don't care about how much
you know until they know about how much
you care if you had breakfast with
Donald Trump you would never forget
every moment of that breakfast say oh
I've had two eggs scrambled the bacon
the hash browns and we got these
delicious sweet potato biscuits and I
put a ton of butter on them I'll never
forget that morning you will remember
but I ask you what did you have for
breakfast and most people are gonna be
like what did I have for breakfast I
can't remember because you don't care
yeah your brain's like I'm like I'm not
gonna store this it's garbage
information yeah I'll say this uh I I
really like Trump I would love to see
Trump elected in 2024 like I said I
won't make any predictions or claims
about who's ultimately going to be
electable between the two but you can
really like both of these guys I
understand that when it comes to the
primary season you're gonna have to make
a choice 100 I will say for as much as I
do love Trump I think that if DeSantis
is successful at whatever he does that's
good for America if DeSantis is a good
governor of Florida that's going to be
good for America if he does end up
becoming president I think that's going
to be good for America if he ends up
being vice president to Donald Trump
that's also going to be good for America
but I do think the Santa's going to be
more successful if he works on fixing
this Charisma problem yeah and and
people have been saying it for a long
time when we had Milo on the show and he
said it was like when you reach for
something and you accidentally touch
something moist like a wet sponge
like I wouldn't go that far that's the
thing like I I wouldn't tell otherwise
Milo does when you have people saying
hey this is a Charisma problem here yeah
and then they the campaign doesn't take
it seriously that that video that Ron
put out on his Twitter should never have
seen the light of day I would not sell
my coffee with something so tepid yeah
for a presidential announcement you need
something big and you need strength
conviction make me believe it I I need I
I'm you know what I'm gonna do we're
gonna make a commercial and I'm gonna
make you believe that buying Casper
coffee will literally save the world I
will put all of the conviction that I
have in it and
I'll make an impassioned plea you know
what I'll do here's what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna take Rhonda Santos's
presidential announcement speech
I'm going to deliver it but instead of
saying I'm running for president I'm
going to say and that's why I'm selling
you coffee so join the fight today and
go to castbrew.com and buy rise with
Roberto Jr because if you don't
this country will fall
or something like that
and then it'll just be like people be
like bro is this coffee calm down
these things going wrong on your first
day of opening a coffee shop though like
you want to have this product like you
said perfected so that when it's coming
out everybody in their first day in your
coffee shop it's gonna be like wow this
is incredible I'm coming back I don't
know if that goal was achieved today you
know I'm gonna make a video
is what I'm gonna do and then Sheamus
can animate it it'll be me doing wrong
understand this speech but saying you
have to buy chickens bye chickens well
I'll say this this is sort of an
Infamous story in political history but
I'm sure you're all familiar with the
the Kennedy Nixon debates uh in 1960 and
everyone who heard it on the radio
thought that Nixon crushed and everyone
who saw it on television thought that
Kennedy won right that's the whole point
of all of this Public Image and how it's
presented to people matters a lot and so
you could say his policies are the best
in the world but if they're not in a
pres if they're not presented in a way
which is uh which is packaged in a way
such that the average American person is
going to be receptive to it it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter all right
everybody if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and head over to
timcast.com click join us become a
member because the members only
uncensored portion starts in a few
minutes and you don't want to miss it
not so family friendly you've been
warned you can follow the show at
timcast IRL you can follow me personally
at timcast Tyler do you want to shout
anything out
ah we've got like I said Turning Point
action has this big conference coming up
in July so July 15th and 16th we're
putting on this huge thing we just
announced today that Donald Trump will
be there uh Vivek will be there we have
a huge host of number of people that are
going to be there you can go to
tpaction.com
just go to tpaction.com and check it out
and and it's gonna be huge I think the
biggest event of the summer cool right
on
um Seamus Coughlin I run a YouTube
channel called Freedom Tunes we're going
to be uploading three videos next week
if you guys want to go check those out I
also have a podcast called shamer we air
every Thursday at 6 00 p.m Eastern
that's Eastern not Easter I'm sorry
what's wrong with me only once a year
only once a year on 6 p.m on Easter
rumble.com shamer y'all go check that
out
I am uh philibonti I am Phil that
remains on Twitter Philip remains
official on Instagram the band is All
That Remains available on Apple music
Spotify YouTube
etc etc
and I am serge.com that was a good show
I'm excited for the after let's get to
it guys we will see you all at
timcast.com in a few minutes thanks for
hanging out